Orge, da bin ich. Ich muss mir jetzt aber noch mal kurz
Neues T-Shirt anziehen. Ich bin gerade gerannt. Gleich wieder am Start
Jetzt aber. Oh, ich muss mein Headset wieder umstecken, gell? Weil es rauscht, Leute.
Ich hab das wieder zurückgestöpselt. Warte mal, ich stöpsel mal um,
dass es wieder besser klingt.
Und zwar musste ich ja... Ich, da mute ich euch mal kurz, weil sonst macht es gleich
Orge
jetzt besser, ne?
So, jetzt war mal den Sound noch mal ein bisschen leiser. Also ich habe noch nichts eingestellt. Ich bin...
Ich bin heute 8... Ich sag's euch, ich bin heute...
Ich bin hier noch ein bisschen geschwitzt.
Kurz Lautstärke einstellen.
Okay.
Ja, so ist gut.
Alles klar. So, auf geht's. Ja, weil
ich bin heute
58, 59... 59 Minuten
bin ich heute gerannt. 8,25 Kilometer.
Das heißt im Durchschnitt ungefähr sieben Minuten pro Kilometer.
Mit
53 Puls. Ich bin absichtlich ein bisschen langsamer gerannt, da ich nicht komplett im Arsch bin.
Aber nachdem das halt knapp eine Stunde gedauert hat
und ich erst 7 Uhr
45 oder so losgerannt bin,
war ich auch... Also ich bin quasi die 8 Uhr 51 oder so die Treppe hoch.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, oh Mist, jetzt musst du eigentlich gleich streamen machen. Du musst dich aber auch noch umziehen ins Klo.
Deswegen war ich jetzt erst mal fünf Minuten...
Moin. Der Gelnhausen-Dude ist wieder am Start. Da wollte ich letztens sogar... Ne, Moment. Sorry, ich verwechsele. Da wollte ich nicht hin.
Ich wollte nach Wiesbaden. Da ist so ein Fahrradladen, wo ich was gucken wollte.
Wobei in Gelnhausen bestimmt auch. Gibt ja überall welche.
Ja, Leute, ich hab mir ernsthaft überlegt, ich hol mir noch ein Fahrrad.
Irgendwie... Irgendwie hab ich's jetzt mit...
Bewegungs-Champ.
Bald gibt's Fitness-Champ, neue App von mir.
Wobei Fitness-Champ ist viel zu, viel zu 0815. Das müsste
Movement-Champ oder irgendwas dummes heißen.
Sport-Champ.
Ne, plötzlich, aber
irgendwie, irgendwie hab ich's jetzt so. Und ich mein, hey, solange noch gutes Wetter ist, macht das ja auch noch mal, macht das ja auch noch mal mehr Bock.
Das ist sehr gut zu wissen.
Das ist, das ist, das ist wirklich gut zu wissen.
Hm.
Also ich, ich bin, ich bin gerade so ein bisschen am gucken,
was ich mir holen will. Aber wenn du in einem, wenn du in einem Bike-Shop arbeitest, fährst, du fährst bestimmt ja auch selber.
Also,
was würdest du mir denn raten,
wenn ich sagen würde, ich will hauptsächlich... Ne, ne, ne, kein E-Bike.
Kein E-Bike. Also ich will, ich will hauptsächlich Fahrrad fahren, so eine Mischung aus,
ganz normal, eben auf Fahrradweg, aber auch mal so den einen oder anderen Waldweg mit so ein bisschen Schotter.
Da gibt's ja so, so all in, all in one, all round Bikes.
Und da habe ich allerdings gelesen, dass das alles zurzeit enorm schlecht lieferbar ist.
Das kann auch ruhig ein bisschen was kosten. Ich will keinen Kack, ja.
Ne, das, das ist so wieder zum geradeaus lange...
Also, ich habe jetzt, ich habe jetzt geguckt, die Kategorie nennt sich, glaube ich, Gravel-Bike. Das heißt ja so viel wie Kies, glaube ich.
Ich meine, übersetzt wird es, glaube ich, mit Schotter, aber ich glaube direkt, ich glaube direkt heißt es Kies, oder?
Heißt das auf Deutsch? Kies, ja.
Alle wollen günstig los, wenn die auch sollen, mir recht sein. Also, ich, ich
würde schon mir gern was Gescheites kaufen.
Die Dinge aus der Trimax Fahrradtour. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der, was, was hat Trimax denn auf seiner Fahrradtour gefahren?
Die sind doch nicht E-Bike gefahren, oder?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die eine Fahrradtour gemacht haben.
Ich kenne, ich kenne nur noch, ich kenne nur noch die, ähm,
die Longboard-Tour. Kennt auch irgendjemand die Longboard-Tour?
Ich habe das, ich habe das damals nie so großartig verfolgt, aber natürlich, man, man hat ja mitbekommen.
Man, man hat es ja mitbekommen, ne?
Ich gucke jetzt gerade mal mal Bilder.
So sind auch ganz normal...
Was ist das für ein Fahrrad, Alter?
Was zum Teufel sind die denn da rumgefahren?
Na gut, es war wahrscheinlich, dass sie ein bisschen mehr Gepäck mitnehmen können.
Guckt mal hier.
Ich glaube, das war's.
Na gut, es war wahrscheinlich, dass sie ein bisschen mehr Gepäck mitnehmen können.
Guckt mal hier.
Trimax Fahrrad.
WTF?
Na sowas will ich nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, dass sie massig Gepäck mitnehmen können, oder?
Hatten die da auch noch?
Ist da noch ein Akku drin und ein Motor?
Ja, aber warum nicht?
Man muss immer das Richtige nehmen für den richtigen Zweck.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Bestimmt wurden die von...
Garantiert. Garantiert.
100 Pro.
Ist ja eine super Gelegenheit für alle.
Ja.
So, und wie gesagt, ich bin mir gerade überlegen,
noch ein Fahrrad zu kaufen.
Aber da muss man ja schon so mit...
Du hast dir das gekauft.
Sowas in der Richtung
habe ich auch schon geguckt,
aber nicht das. Das ist ja quasi ein reines Rennrad, oder?
Nee, das ist kein Rennrad.
Das ist irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung, was das für eins ist.
Ein Crossbike Fitness.
Ja, das sind die Dinger,
die du dir auch mal tragen kannst.
Zumindest muss man da,
wenn ich mir das hier schon angucke,
auch in andere Richtungen,
muss man da schon durchaus mal mit 2000 Euro rechnen.
Und was witzig ist,
dass die ganzen Fahrräder keine Pedale haben,
aber ist auch klar, weil das wohl was sehr Individuelles ist,
was die Leute da haben wollen.
Aha.
So, dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Was geht denn so
auf Shithub ab?
Und diese Woche
ist einiges passiert, Leute.
Ich habe gehört, AVM
will unter den Hammer
Gatschibass
AVM will sich verkaufen.
Bestimmt am Ende an irgendwelche China-Chinesen
oder so.
Äh, BlackHD, dankeschön für den Sub.
Und hier, wen haben wir noch?
Nee, haben wir keinen. Exzellent. Gut, ich hatte doch schon was vergessen.
Trinken, Leute. Ich muss mir unbedingt gleich neuen Tee holen.
Es ist fast leer.
Und ich habe laut App
Ähm, also
Ich habe laut App
8,25 Kilometer
habe ich
verbraucht an
Schweiß.
982 Milliliter.
Also ich habe gerade ungefähr ein Kilo Wasser rausgeschwitzt.
Also
Ich muss noch ein bisschen was nachfüllen.
Oh, was ist das?
Meine App meint Congratulations
New Achieve
Äh, Englisch, Englisch Satz.
Congratulations on achieving
a new personal best.
Okay, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, was mein
new personal best ist, weil ich war wirklich nicht schnell unterwegs
heute. Ah, longest run.
8,25 Kilometer.
Okay, okay.
Ja, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass das ein Achievement
in der App ist.
Aber dann accepten wir mal das Achievement.
Nächster
Meilenstein ist
10 Kilometer durchhalten.
Und dann bin ich zufrieden.
Das ist wirklich
die App ist wirklich ganz gut gemacht.
Dann bin ich zufrieden, wenn ich 10 Kilometer schaffe
dann
mehr muss es nicht sein.
Also mein mittelfristiges Ziel
ist, dass ich 10 Kilometer schaffe unter
6 Minuten
pro Kilometer.
Also aktuell schaffe ich 5 Kilometer
unter 6 Minuten
also unter
6 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Also das heißt 5 Minuten, mein Rekord ist glaube ich
gerade
5 Kilometer in
Minuten 37.
Also müsste ich quasi unter 60 Minuten
also 10 Kilometer unter 60 Minuten
das ist so das, was ich
jetzt erstmal
in näherer Zukunft auf die Reihe kriegen will.
Dann ist es erstmal gut.
Nächstes Jahr Frankfurt Marathon, ja ganz bestimmt.
Nein, nicht Fahrrad.
Nicht Fahrrad.
Mit Fahrrad wäre das ganz schön lahm.
Fahrrad habe ich
ja auch noch keins.
Kann ich auch noch nicht fahren.
So, also BUN
Trended. Ja, das müssen wir uns demnächst
auch mal angucken.
JavaScript
Das kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden, wie laut
es sein soll.
JavaScript. Ist BUN
mit NPM kompatibel?
Weil das ist ja eigentlich eines der
größten Pluspunkte des JavaScript
Ökosystems
dass es für fast jeden Furz irgendeine
Library gibt.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass
JetBrains eine Rust IDE
rausgebracht hat? Nein, aber das finde ich sehr nice.
Wie heißt es? Rust Mine?
Oder was? Rust
Die Rust Rover.
Na gut, Rust Mine wäre ja auch
ziemlich bescheuert. Ruby gibt es ja schon bei Ruby.
Außerdem passt es zu Rust nicht.
Rust
Rover
Eine brandneue JetBrains IDE
für Rust Entwickler.
Das gucken wir uns mal kurz
an, das Video.
Das gucken wir uns mal kurz an, was das Tolles kann.
Wann kam denn das? Das ist das schon eine
ganze Weile. Ist schon ein bisschen älter, gell?
Aber das ist gut.
Ich dürfte Rust auf jeden Fall noch mal
einen ordentlichen Boost verleihen, weil ich glaube
eines der nervigsten Sachen in Rust
neben
äußerst komplexer Syntax
und auch echt ein bisschen
Einstiegs, wie soll man sagen,
hoher Lernkurve, ist
die IDE Experience.
Du hast zwar bisher schon
die ganzen JetBrains bzw. IntelliJ
Plugins, die ganz okay waren.
Visual Studio Code ging es auch halbwegs
halbwegs gescheit. Also wirklich gut
empfand ich da als nix,
wo ich da bisher mit rumgebastelt hab.
Heißt im Endeffekt, das dürfte noch mal richtig
was bringen.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken, was das Ding kann.
Rust! Rewrite
in Rust, placingly fast.
Okay, ich find schon mal gut,
dass die keinen Sound haben.
Das ist schon mal nice, können wir hier
gedudelt laufen lassen.
Was ich auch cool finde, dass die keinen Sound haben, weil
normalerweise hast du in diesen Werbevideos
oder vielleicht ist die auch nur mal ein Browser, der keinen Sound
spielen kann. Wobei,
nee, das ist Chrome, Chrome kann auf jeden Fall Sound
abspielen. Oder vielleicht
haben die irgendeinen Codec, den nur Firefox kann.
Das glaub ich jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt
nicht. Nee, die haben einfach keinen
Sound. Was ich persönlich nicht schlecht find,
weil diese ganzen Werbevideos,
die haben immer alle diesen gleichen
Werbevideosound.
So, weißt ja,
dieses super fröhliche
belanglose Hintergrundgeklimper.
Die haben alle immer
fast den gleichen Sound, die ganzen Werbevideos.
So, Rust.
Placingly fast.
Klepp.
Klepp, das kenn ich sogar, das ist ein Command-Line-Parser,
der mich fast zur Verzweiflung gebracht hat.
Jira Service startet.
Pog.
Du meinst, du machst Jira,
ihr habt ein Ticketsystem im Fahrradshop.
Ja stimmt, warum nicht?
Je nachdem, wie groß das ist.
Jira.
Das ist gut,
dass sie hier direkte Crate und
Cargo-Gedöns-Unterstützung haben, weil
Rust ist halt
so ein Ding.
Du brauchst halt für jedes Rust-Projekt
gefühlt 80
Packages. Okay, nice.
Ordentliches Autocomplete, was nicht abkackt
nach ner Zeit, dürfte wahrscheinlich echt das beste
sein.
Mich würde mal interessieren, auf was
die aufsetzen. Ob die
auf diesen Rust-Language
Services, oder wie das heißt,
aufsetzen. Oder
ob die da wieder
quasi alles fast selbst drumrum
gestrickt haben. Bei .NET ist es
ja so halbe-halbe. Die
benutzen Microsoft-Zeug, allerdings haben sie
sehr viel drumrum gestrickt. Beispielsweise
äh
Lautstärke der
Playlist ist auch extremely
pega. Da haben sie ja bei .NET
haben sie ja auch viel drumrum gestrickt.
Da haben sie ihr
ReSharper-Zeug genommen, haben noch einen
eigenen Debugger und alles drumrum gebaut für Ryder,
weil das Microsoft-Zeug sich nicht gescheit
integrieren ließ.
Ähm, Browser
ich hätte das gerne im Fullscreen.
Okay, Refactor-Rename.
Okay.
Rust-Dinger.
Die Rust-Syntax ist teilweise schon
echt ein bisschen abartig, ne.
Hier mit TestRunner dabei.
Okay, nice. Direkt
Direkt-Integration von
Backend-Web-Server
gedönst, finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Kannste nachgucken, welcher
Request auf welchen Breakpoint trifft.
Gut, die
üblichen JetBrains-Shit-
Features, die ich nicht verwende,
weil Command-Line-Git eins
ich wahre, beste, und jeder, der
was anderes nutzt, highly pepega.
Weil
ich's so sag.
Ja, nicht schlecht.
Könnte man sich tatsächlich
demnächst mal geben.
So, also.
Was trendet denn
diese Woche?
BAN. Ja, wie gesagt,
das müssen wir uns mal bei Gelegenheit angucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, hat BAN, hat da jemand was drauf gegeben?
Ist BAN-NPM-
Packages kompatibel?
Aha.
Okay, nice.
Das ist ein riesen Vorteil,
warum das Deno nicht von Anfang an hatte, verstehe ich nicht.
Aber das ist gut.
Weil eines der größten Vorteile
vom gesamten Javascript-
Ökosystem ist ja eben die Package-Anzahl.
Und natürlich auch, ist odd und ist even.
Wie kann man ohne die essenziellsten
NPM-Packages überhaupt programmieren?
So, Java-Zeug,
AI,
Game-Engine,
wo ich mir
sagen lassen hab, dass man das Go-Do
ausspricht und nicht Go-Dot.
Ich dachte immer, es heißt Go-Dot,
weil ich mir das nie angeguckt hab
und dachte, es ist halt in Go programmiert.
Bis ich mir das irgendwann mal angeschaut hab,
hab ich festgestellt, nee, das hat mit Go überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Nicht eine Zeile Go in dem gesamten Projekt.
Unity is dead.
Stimmt, das war die Woche auch noch,
dass Unity ihre Lizenzbedingungen
geändert hat, irgendwie retroaktiv
für schon veröffentlichte Games
ab dem 1.1.
2024 und sowas.
Alter, das ist auch so ein Ding,
wo ich mir gedacht hab, was denkt sich
der Unity-CEO? Denkt er sich
irgendwie so, ey, Speedrun
zu Company Sale?
So nach dem Motto, nice, da krieg ich nochmal fett
Millionen und hab ausgesorgt. Oder ich hab keine Ahnung,
was dort der Hintergedanke
ist. Ja, kann ich auch verstehen.
Ich weiß echt nicht,
was die sich dabei vorstellen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
so ein Ex-EA-CEO. Ja, gut,
das ist doch egal, wo der herkommt.
Ich mein, du kannst ja erwarten,
dass er sinnige Entscheidungen trifft. Das heißt, er ist
der Meinung, es ist eine sinnvolle
Entscheidung und da muss man sich immer auch mal
in die andere
Rolle reinfassen, dass er sich überlegt, warum könnte
das eine sinnvolle
Entscheidung sein?
Und ich mein, gibt's ja
mehrere Gründe. Entweder, weil er
kurzfristig noch ein bisschen Geld rauspressen will,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Weil er vielleicht wirklich will, dass man das
Ding verkauft und er fett
Kohle nochmal machen kann.
Oder weiß ich nicht, ja.
Da kann man sich viel überlegen.
Aber der hat bestimmt seinen Grund.
Der macht das bestimmt nicht einfach so
random komplett.
Wie gesagt, das könnte durchaus sein,
dass der
vor allem,
wenn er das verkauft, kriegt er wahrscheinlich nochmal
richtig fett Kohle.
Das stimmt auch nur halb.
Das habe ich auch gelesen. Das ist aber auch so
ein typisches Ding, wo man
News und Kommentaren in News
nicht so hundertprozentig vertrauen kann.
Und zwar, ja das stimmt, dass die
ihre Aktien verkauft haben.
Aber es ist nicht so, als hätten
die einen Tag
bevor sie die Ankündigung
gemacht haben, ohne es jemals
jemand zu sagen, ihre Aktien verkauft.
Weil wenn du CEO bist von einem Unternehmen
und willst einen größeren, und der hat auch gar nicht
alle seine Stocks verkauft,
sondern irgendwie plus, keine Ahnung, 5% oder so.
Das mussten die im Vorfeld ankündigen.
Und das haben die auch im Vorfeld angekündigt, weil die sonst
wahrscheinlich mit dem Finanzamt oder sowas bekommen hätten.
Und dementsprechend ist das
stimmt das so, wie das hervorgehoben
wurde in Posts und News und
Comments gar nicht so richtig.
Also die mussten das
bekannt geben.
Ich glaube irgendwie 3 Wochen oder so
vorher schon.
Natürlich wusste man nicht warum.
Und das war es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich gehe nicht
davon aus, dass da irgendjemand für den Knast kommt,
weil die das sicherlich rechtlich korrekt gemacht haben.
So, also was haben wir denn sonst noch
hier auf Shithub?
Ich weiß nicht was das ist, klingt aber irgendwie nach AI, oder?
Diff Beer.
Man hat keine Ahnung was es ist, aber
bestimmt AI. Wenn man nicht weiß was es ist, ist es AI.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
AI.
Der Reponame ist auch AI generated.
Ja, neue Programmiersprache.
Das ist dieses
C++ Python Ding.
Wo mir persönlich nichts zugesagt hat,
weil nichts open source davon ist.
Von der Sprache.
Und wo ich mich frage, wie kann das
2023 überhaupt sein?
Schon merkwürdig, oder?
AI, AI.
China-Chinesen-AI.
Also wenn AI noch getoppt werden kann, dann nur noch
von China-Chinesen-AI.
Decompilatores.
Okay, alles klar.
Rust.
AI.
Stimmt auch AI.
Äh.
Irgendwas für
AirTags, vermutlich?
Apple
Bluetooth Low Energy.
Das ist ja im Prinzip auch was AirTags
verwenden, oder?
Doch, relativ sicher.
Äh.
Sparing Message Spoofing.
Warum?
Okay, hier gibt's schon wieder
irgendwelchen Beef. Kann man
da einen ESP32 pairen als
als AirTag
oder sowas? React Native.
Wir haben
AI, AI, AI.
Bert.
Ein
FITS2 Backbone
with Bert. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das
sein soll.
TLDraw. Very
good whiteboard.
Very good whiteboard. Leute, hier.
Porgas Whiteboard.
Massive.
Was sagst du zum neuen iPhone 15
Pro? Ich hab nur gelesen, dass
das angekündigt wurde und wieder ultra teuer ist,
aber damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt, also ich hätte auch
nichts mit nichts anderem gerechnet.
Stehen jetzt
eigentlich die Kameras da so weit raus, wie man
ursprünglich vermutet hat?
Ich hab mir das nicht weiter...
Ich hab nur gelesen, dass es das jetzt gibt.
Ja, ne? Die Kameras gucken noch weiter
raus als gedacht.
Das alte liegt schon nur noch mit
nur noch mit
Gehäuse halbwegs
flach auf dem Tisch.
Ich meine, ich darf nichts
sagen. Ich hab mir auch einen
iPhone
Was hab ich denn überhaupt? 14 Pro, glaube ich,
geholt. Aber nicht
Max und sonst was. Das
ging noch. Ich hab glaube ich 1200 Euro bezahlt
und das ist auch schon mega krass dämlich teuer.
Wie
gefällt dir Baldur's Gate 3?
Also, ich
hab's noch nicht durch. Der dritte Akt
lässt extrem nach.
In allen
Bereichen. Story,
Polishing,
Bugs,
so genereller
Flow, Dialoge,
Sachen, an was man
gedacht hat. Also der dritte Akt ist wirklich noch
ziemlich unfinished.
Insgesamt muss ich
sagen,
ich finde, Baldur's
Gate 3 ist ein gutes Game geworden.
Aber Baldur's Gate
3 ist nicht das beste Game
ever made, das beste RPG ever
made oder sonst was.
Wie das teilweise in Reviews geschrieben wird.
Die wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden oder so gespielt haben,
Akt 1, keine Ahnung.
Ich finde, Baldur's Gate 3 ist viel zu leicht
und ich finde,
nicht alle Anpassungen,
gerade was Kämpfe angeht,
super gelungen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein nices Game.
Ich glaube, Baldur's Gate 3 ist fast eher was
für Leute, die auf
ausgefeilte
Dialoge und
ihre Konsequenzen
daraus und Entscheidungen
stehen, weniger
auf Fights. Also ich muss sagen,
in Kämpfen selbst ist
Baldur's Gate 3 gar nicht mal so gut.
Also alle, die auf
Dungeons & Dragons möglichst original
stehen, kommen in Baldur's Gate 3 auf jeden Fall
nicht auf ihre Kosten. Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Ich finde, es muss ein Game auch nicht.
Was auch schon die ersten
Baldur's Gate Icewind Dales nicht hatten.
Die waren auch schon teilweise recht weit weg
von der Vorlage. Ist aber auch nicht schlimm.
Aber dafür
ist es wieder zu nah an der
Vorlage, weil beispielsweise
bei kaum einem Level-Up irgendwas passiert.
Also Character Progression hat
Baldur's Gate 3
sehr verhalten.
Da ist es tatsächlich am nächsten an der
Vorlage dran. Weil
Level-Ups machen kaum einen Unterschied.
Bis auf manche
Key-Level. Aber ansonsten passiert da
nichts pro Level-Up. Also das war
in Divinity tatsächlich deutlich PC-Spiel
freundlicher.
Also für jemand, der
diesen Dialog-
Role-Playing-Aspekt mag,
ist Baldur's Gate 3 nice.
Es ist für alle zu empfehlen,
die gerne RPGs spielen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht das
beste RPG ever made oder sowas,
wo sie sich teilweise ereifert haben
überall. Auch
muss sehr viel, und das kann man ihnen jetzt aber nicht
vorwerfen, weil letztendlich müssen wir das Produkt bewerten,
was rausgekommen ist.
Letztendlich muss sehr viel Content
fehlen, der noch angekündigt
war. Beispielsweise fehlen ganze
Stadtviertel in Baldur's Gate.
Wo es teilweise auch massig Content
schon gab im Early Access,
der wohl gestrichen wurde. Aber gut, letztendlich ist
ihre Entscheidung, wie sie es rausbringen.
Muss halt passen. Ich muss ehrlich
sagen, die Story hat mich nicht abgeholt
von Baldur's Gate 3.
Ich glaube, das ist aber so ein typischer Fall,
man mag es oder man hasst es.
Ich fande
Mindflayer in Divinity noch nie sonderlich
was weiß ich
irgendwie spannend.
Auch wenn es ein recht großer Lore-
Teil ist.
Craggy, dankeschön für den Sub.
Und es ist
viel zu viel Fokus auf diese ganze Mindflayer-
Geschichte.
Der eigentliche, ich werde jetzt nicht spoilern,
aber der eigentliche Story-Twist, so
Ende Akt 2,
hat man irgendwie schon ein bisschen
kommen sehen,
was hinter dem Absolut
steckt.
Aber das fand ich noch ganz
gut, tatsächlich.
Aber es ist mir zu viel
Mindflayer gedirnt.
Und auch sehr langsam. Im Prinzip ist
die Story von Baldur's Gate 3 echt
die kannst du in einer Seite
zusammenfassen, easy. Oder in einer halben Seite
easy zusammenfassen.
Ich fand die jetzt nicht sonderlich...
Da fand ich viele Side-
Quests und Storys tatsächlich
interessanter.
Es ist
ein gutes Game.
Ja, wäre halt aber auch kein guter Abschluss
gewesen. Akt 2 Ende war tatsächlich
ziemlich nice.
Ich weiß nicht.
Doch, Baldur's Gate 3 ist das
einsteigerfreundlichste so
Classic-RPG der letzten Jahre.
Das ist das Einfachste
und Beste, wie du einsteigen kannst.
Die haben sogar halbwegs gute
Premade-Characters diesmal.
Ich hab nichts gespoilert.
Akt 2 Ende war aber echt
nice. Also es ist auf jeden Fall
einsteigerfreundlich.
Mir fällt eigentlich kein einsteigerfreundliches
so Classic-RPG ein.
Divinity
ist auf jeden Fall schwieriger.
Also es ist nicht nur schwieriger,
sondern auf höherem Schwierigkeitsgrad
deutlich schwieriger.
Man muss wissen, was man
macht.
Ich persönlich,
wobei in Baldur's Gate 3
ist alles voice acted, aber es ist halt viel Dialog.
Das stimmt. Also ich muss ehrlich
sagen, wenn ich Gameplay
technisch die Auswahl
hätte zwischen Baldur's Gate 3
und
Pathfinder
Wrath of the Righteous, würde ich sagen Pathfinder.
Gameplay
technisch.
Ich mag Realtime with Pause
und
das gesamte Charakter
tweaken, optimieren auf höherem
Schwierigkeitsgrad ist Pathfinder einfach
nahezu unerreicht.
Pathfinder ist auch ziemlich unfertig im letzten Akt.
Wird sich wahrscheinlich, außer vielleicht
noch durch richtig große Modgis,
nichts mehr dran ändern. Die haben ja schon so eine Premium Edition
rausgebracht,
aber das hat
nicht so viel geändert.
Der letzte Akt ist auch ziemlich
unfertig, aber das scheint ja mittlerweile fast
normal zu sein.
Wohin ging Baldur's Gate 1?
Hatte einen richtig guten, das war eigentlich fast das
beste am Game, der letzte Akt.
Naja. Ich würde halt
sagen, rein für, rein für
Dialoge, Roleplaying
und
Auswahl, die man hat
und Konsequenzen daraus, dann würde ich
sagen, Spylo's Gate 3 schon besser.
Und wenn irgendjemand mal wirklich
relativ raw Dungeons & Dragons
5th Edition Rules spielen will,
der sollte sich mal
Solasta angucken.
Das ist mehr oder weniger
also wörtlich
die, außer dass die Charakter
halt mega beschissen aussehen,
das ist mehr oder weniger wörtlich
die
Dungeons & Dragons
5th Ausgabe Regeln, die haben
natürlich auch bescheuerte, bescheuerte Screenshots,
umgesetzt in einem PC-Spiel.
Also Solasta ist wirklich
nice für jemand, der mal die
raw Dungeons & Dragons Experience
in einem PC-Spiel haben will.
Man kann nicht die
Story und nicht das
Production Value erwarten von
Baldur's Gate und die
Charaktermodels sehen teilweise schon echt
bescheuert aus, aber
es ist
Gameplay-technisch fight-mäßig
wirklich ziemlich nah dran
an der Vorlage.
Ich muss mir gleich noch einen Tee holen.
So, hatten wir jetzt eigentlich
ShitHub fertig geguckt? Ich glaube schon, gell?
Ja, wir hatten ShitHub fertig geguckt.
Lass uns mal ganz schnell
durchscrollen,
was es in der .NET-Welt gibt.
Dapper keckelbär benutzen das nach
Remote-Uni-Hackers, Steam-Tools...
Maui. Wisst ihr was?
Ich würde...
Es ist schade, dass man nicht
auf Software-Projekte irgendwie wetten kann.
Ich bin ja kein großer Glücksspiel-Fan,
aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen, da würde ich gerne
drauf wetten. Und ich würde zum Beispiel
gerne drauf wetten, dass innerhalb der
nächsten zwei, drei Jahre
Maui eingestellt wird von Microsoft.
Weil es keine Sau verwendet und
es suckt. Und Microsoft bekannt
dafür ist, UI-Frameworks einfach
abzusägen. Nachdem es noch
eine Woche zuvor als
das beste seit geschnitten Brot oder
Erfindung des Rats verkauft wurde.
Irgendwelche Maui-User hier
im Chat? Also schauen wir mal
in Bylight, ja? Und falls ja, wie
findet ihr es? Außer
buggy as fuck.
Und kein Linux-Support.
Dann lieber Avalonia,
wenn es sein muss. Spannend ist drin.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon gesehen habt.
Windows Forms. Ja, mit Windows Forms
kommt man ja auch klar, wenn es Windows-Only und
kurz und knackig sein soll.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gesehen habt,
aber AVM, also
Fritzbox-Hersteller
und Fritz-Phone und
Fritz-Smart
und alles Fritz-Fritzige,
die wollen
sich selbst verkaufen.
Weil, also eins der Hauptgründe
muss wohl sein, weil die Gründer mittlerweile
irgendwie an die 70 sind und nicht wissen,
wie lange sie es noch machen und
wie lange sie das noch durchhalten.
Keine Ahnung. Ich frage mich auch,
warum sie keine Nachfolger finden,
die AVM weiterführt wie bisher.
Weil man muss ja sagen, AVM läuft's ja
wohl ganz gut.
In Zukunft muss man halt mal schauen,
wenn DSL weniger relevant wird
und
wenn man für Glasfaser
mehr oder weniger
jeden 0.8.15 besseren
Computer benutzen kann mit
einem
SFP-Plus-Port,
falls das so sein wird.
Mal gucken.
Aber trotzdem braucht man ja noch Zusatzfunktionen
wie beispielsweise Deck-Basis-Station
und ich finde, gerade was Thermostate
angeht, ist Fritz-Zeug nicht schlecht.
Das kann sein.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
weil bei mir wird's wahrscheinlich
in nächster Zeit mit Ausbau auch nix,
weil wir ja schon Gigabit-Kabel haben und
das ist ja auch nicht so schlecht.
Das ist ja auch nicht so schlecht.
Ja, wir gucken jetzt mal...
Nee, bis...
Bis...
Von irgendwas bis 2002.
Nee, das ist noch zu früh.
Es hat nämlich vor Jahren mal
der Oberbürgermeister
von Hanau
großspurig erzählt,
wir werden in drei Jahren oder so...
Ja, das kann sein.
Nee, das ist...
Großspurig erzählt...
Ja.
2015.
Ich find's jetzt nicht.
Da haben sie groß erzählt,
dass es ausgebaut wird
und dass wir bis 2020
flächendeckend Fiber-to-the-home haben.
Und damals hab ich mir schon gedacht...
Wer es glaubt...
Und das hat ja auch nicht geklappt,
aber hat man natürlich nie wieder was von gehört.
So, und AVM, wie gesagt,
AVM möchte sich
verkaufen.
Ob das jetzt so gut ist für
uns
als Leute, die
AVM-Geräte kaufen möchten
in Zukunft, vielleicht weiß man nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich wird das an irgendeiner
Geldgebergruppe verkauft
und die
pressen noch das letzte an Kohle
raus und verkaufen es dann weiter.
Und dann geht's den Bach runter.
Irgendwie sowas. Ich bin mal gespannt,
was da rauskommt.
Ja, und was es diese Woche auch noch
als Aufreger gab, war diese Unity-Geschichte.
Okay,
die Leute übertreiben es aber auch immer.
Meine Fresse, Alter.
Sollen sie den Kram halt nicht über...
Die übertreiben
es immer, Mann.
Ja, und weil Unity gesagt hat,
ab 1.1. wollen sie
auch für schon veröffentlichte Spiele Gebühren verlangen.
Da gehe
ich ja eigentlich auch mal von aus, aber man weiß es nicht.
Moment, Moment.
Das
hab ich nicht gesagt.
Ich hab gesagt, bei mir gibt es schon
Gigabit-Kabel und deswegen wird das wahrscheinlich mit Ausbau
in nächster Zeit nichts.
Das ist ja nichts, was ich jetzt sagen würde.
Weißt du, das ist ja nicht so, als ruft die Telekom bei mir
an und sagt, Max, wir würden dir gerne
Fiber to the Home legen und ich sag, nee, nee,
ich hab Kabel.
Das wird auf der Ebene entschieden,
dass ich gar nichts dazu sagen darf.
Da wird geguckt, in dem Gebiet gibt es
ja schon Kabel, Gigabit, also
bauen wir dort nicht aus. Ist nicht so, als hätte ich da irgendwas
zu sagen.
Das wäre ja lustig.
Moment, Moment.
Unity.
Update.
Wo ist das Update?
Ihr habt es verkackt.
Steht nichts dazu da.
Aber,
naja, komm, wir gucken jetzt nicht weiter.
Robsen.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wie gesagt, ich hab gerade gelesen,
dass es Morddrohungen gegeben hat für Unity,
aber ob das die von Mitarbeitern sein sollen,
hab ich nirgendwo gelesen bisher.
Echt, steht das da drin?
Ach, hier.
Die Polizei von San Francisco teilt jedoch später mit,
Unity habe einen eigenen
Mitarbeiter als Urheber der Drohungen
angegeben.
Oh Mann.
Okay, der ist wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal
arbeitslos.
Aber da sieht man, die sind auch
ziemlich abgefuckt davon,
so wie es aussieht.
Die Entscheidung scheint ja richtig Rückhalt zu haben
in der Firma.
Verstehe ich nicht, wie man sowas nicht machen kann,
machen möchte.
Das wird, also wenn man das in Zukunft
mal irgendwie für einen ordentlichen Preis
noch weiter vermieten will,
dann muss das Ding Gigabit haben.
Ich verstehe nicht, wie die Leute so pipegas sein können.
Das ist wie mein Opa, ja?
Damals, als die
die Straße aufgemacht haben,
also damals ist schon wohl wirklich lange her,
um Kabel zu verlegen für Kabelfernsehen
und später Internet und sowas,
aber das war ja damals nicht, hat mein Opa gesagt,
nein, an mein Haus
kommt nix dran. Also,
alle beiden Nachbarn hatten das,
aber mein Opa hat gesagt, nein, bei mir wird
nichts angeschlossen.
Ich hab doch meine Antenne auf dem Dach.
Und er hat dann,
der hat dann richtig Probleme später mit dem Empfang gehabt
und alles.
Wollte noch eine satte Lintenschüssel
und das war auch Mist, wegen der Posi
und so. Das war eines der ersten Sachen,
die wir damals gemacht haben, hier
2013 in dem Haus.
Noch ein Anschluss für Kabel,
nicht unbedingt
nur für Fernsehen,
weil mich persönlich interessiert Fernsehen halt gar nicht,
sondern auch die Option zu haben,
anderen
Internetprovider zu nehmen, als irgendwas
auf Kupfer
DSL Telekom
based. Weil da war ja damals
schon abzusehen, dass mit
250 Mbit Super
V Vectoring, wie auch immer das gen...
Wie heißt denn das eigentlich richtig? Super?
Ich glaub einfach nur Super Vectoring,
dass damit Schluss ist
mit dem ganzen DSL Schrott.
Wir hatten's lange noch.
PPPoE
Da hat er wieder einen neuen Kubernetes Cluster daheim.
Der braucht noch 5 weitere.
Was verdient ein Landwirt?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ich glaube, das hat eine richtig
große Range.
Es gibt welche, die das sehr
Business-orientiert machen
und bestimmt auch welche, die das mehr so
rein zur Liebe, zur Natur
machen und ich glaub dementsprechend
unterschiedlich wird da auch
was man da verdient.
Ende von Leder.
Okay, dann lass uns mal gucken, was man als
Landwirt verdient.
Ich würde woanders mehr verdienen.
Wahrscheinlich auch ein ganzes Stück mehr.
Wie man jetzt gerade
unschön sieht, so soll das nicht sein.
Erstmal einen fetten Traktor anschmeißen.
Ich würde woanders mehr verdienen.
Wahrscheinlich auch ein ganzes Stück mehr.
Wie man jetzt gerade
unschön sieht, so soll das nicht sein.
Ich hab für den
Ausbau ein Kredit aufgenommen.
6000 Euro.
Wow.
Hi, ich bin Hans, bin 25 Jahre alt
und arbeite
als Landwirt auf unserem Familienbetrieb
zusammen mit meinem Vater.
Und das hier ist unser Hof.
5.15 Uhr. Alter, bin ich...
Ich bin früher 5.45 Uhr
aufgestanden und ich war eigentlich nicht
überlebensfähig in der Zeit.
Ich hab mich von müde zu müde gehangelt.
Jetzt schnappen wir uns
die Schaufel und machen die Liegeboxen
sauber und treiben die Kühe alle
zum Melkstand.
Jetzt wird erstmal abgezapft.
Wenn im Stall zum Beispiel
eine Kuh krank wird, eigentlich
passiert fast jeden Tag
irgendwas Unvorhersehbares.
Da ist ja auch viel.
Mit 84!
Mit 84 ist der Opa um 5 Uhr schon
im Stall. Na gut, das macht er wahrscheinlich
jedem lang, aber der ist gut drauf.
Erstmal schön die Scheiße zusammenfegen.
Chatge.
Was machst du
morgens alles,
dass du quasi 1,5 Stunden oder so
aufstehen musst, bevor du aus dem Haus gehst?
Mein Opa ist auch übelst früh aufgestanden,
aber der ist danach nicht in Stallarbeit.
Kacken.
1,5 Stunden, ja gut, wenn's muss, das muss.
Wupp los gucken. Ja, morgens um 5 Uhr.
Klar.
Also ich stehe um
ziemlich genau um 7 Uhr auf.
Mittlerweile. Nicht mal 5.45 Uhr
wie früher.
7.
Und ich fang dann so um
8.45 Uhr an.
Okay.
Ich hab Panischlärm. Morgens.
Letztendlich muss jeder was finden,
was für sich gut funktioniert.
Die Milch ist unser Hauptproduktionszweig.
Und damit
machen wir vorrangig unser Geld.
Wir liefern am Tag
ungefähr 1.300 Liter
Milch ab.
Und das sind beim derzeitigen
Milchpreis von 35 Cent.
400 Euro ca. am Tag.
Sozusagen Umsatz, kein Gewinn.
Los.
Komm.
Die 36 ist eine Stinkstiefel,
die ärgert gern mal die anderen Kühe.
Ja.
Die sind auch sehr träge.
Na los.
Langsam dick und ärgert die anderen Leute.
Hm.
Komm.
Da erkennen sich manche bestimmt wieder.
Los rein hier.
Hopp.
Eine Bindung baut man schon auf.
Wie jetzt im konkreten Fall.
Haben keinen Namen für jede einzelne Kuh.
Und natürlich
ist es nicht schön,
wenn man dann eine Kuh abgeben muss.
Aber es ist nicht so,
wie bei einem Haustier,
dass es drei Tage Staatstrau ist,
wenn es diese Kuh nicht mehr gibt.
So.
Ich glaube, damit wirst du auch abgehärtet
mit der Zeit.
Jetzt sind wir schon fertig damit.
Jetzt müssen wir bloß noch mal rüber gehen.
Jetzt hat gerade schon wieder eine Kuh reingekotet.
Gekotet?
Sprich COD.
Danach haben die Kühe wieder
ein frisches Bett.
Normalerweise sagt der doch bestimmt,
da hat schon wieder eine hingekackt.
Das war jetzt
die
gewählte Ausdrucksweise,
während das Fernsehteam da ist.
Das Kalb auch richtig säuft.
Ob alles aussäuft.
Wenn es nicht säuft, dann merkt man schon,
aha, wird das Tier krank.
Natürlich muss man dann schnell handeln.
Komm.
Ich sauf jetzt auch was.
Komm, wolltest du nicht?
Wie man jetzt gerade unschön sieht,
so soll das nicht sein.
Eigentlich müssen die Kälber sofort rangehen
und saufen.
So wie es aussieht, wollen die gar nichts hier.
Na, was ist denn los mit euch?
Ich sehe gerade auch, das hat ein bisschen Durchfall.
Es kann sein, dass sie
wirklich gar nichts wollen.
Also entweder heute Mittag
schauen, ob sie dann saufen.
Und wenn nicht, dann müssen wir vielleicht mal
Fieber messen, ob sie krank werden.
Amometer in the bobbes.
Kommt da ein anderer?
Kommt da ein anderer im September?
Wir haben ja einen kleinen Familienbetrieb,
sage ich mal, mein Vater und ich.
Mit Tieren.
Da würde ich durchdrehen, wenn ich den ganzen Tag
mit meinen Eltern hier irgendwie zusammen hocke,
arbeiten müsste.
Da würde ich durchdrehen.
Mit unseren Milchkühen.
Und man ist zu zweit und da hat man wirklich jeden Tag Arbeit.
Auch zu Weihnachten,
auch zum Geburtstag, zu Ostern.
Ja gut, das ist der Kuh ja egal.
Die scheißt auch am Feiertag.
Leute, die bei schönem Wetter
an den Badesee fahren und so.
Und man kann nicht mit, weil man noch Arbeit zu erledigen hat.
Das sind dann die Schattenseiten.
Hier sind sie, die Kleinen.
Oh.
Wupp, Pet. Und wo ist die Mama?
Traktor fahren ist eigentlich
mit die schönste Arbeit
in meinem ganzen Beruf, sage ich mal.
Aber es ist natürlich nicht nur Traktor fahren.
Ich sage mal, von meiner Zeit so
sind vielleicht 10% von Arbeitszeit
keine Traktorfahrzeit.
Aber natürlich ist es immer schön.
Traktor fahren ist Pog.
Also mein Ziel ist, das Feld heute
PS, auch richtig
outdated, overrated, gebated
Unit.
18 Hektar.
Also 5-6 Stunden am Ende
und fertig sein.
Landwirtschaft ist ja generell
auch ein gefährlicher Beruf.
Es gibt schon
tödliche Verletzungen oder tödliche
Unfälle. Das kommt
nicht so selten vor mit den großen
Maschinen.
Wenn man da in eine Maschine reinkommt,
da sind so viele Leistungen,
die hält da nicht an.
Letztens, ich habe letztens
bei mir im Garten
einen Baumstumpf
entfernen lassen.
Und der Typ, der das gemacht hat,
der hatte auch einen Finger weniger.
Auch gemeint, hat man nicht aufgepasst.
Maschine, Schnippschnapp,
Finger ab.
Wir haben jetzt noch ungefähr
7 Hektar.
6-7 Hektar, das sollte man schaffen.
Jetzt gibt's Mittagessen.
Das ist
indisches Chicken-Curry-Zeug.
Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Das können auch Hähnchen mit Rahmsauce sein.
Das ist eher der Fall.
Jetzt müssen wir auf jeden Fall zu den 2
Kleinkälbern gucken, ob die
jetzt saufen.
Das schlechteste wäre, wenn sie
eine Lungenentzündung bekommen.
Oder wenn sie krank werden.
Kommt her.
Jetzt wird gesuckt.
Es tut auch ein bisschen hecheln.
Ich denke, es könnte doch
anfangen, krank zu werden.
Ich hole gleich mal das Fieberthermometer.
Schauen wir mal, was es sagt.
Das ist ein normales Fieberthermometer.
Warum sollte es da nicht auch gehen?
Das sind jetzt
39 Grad Celsius.
Es ist also schon leicht erhöht.
Wenn es nicht runtergeht,
dann müssen wir einen Tierarzt holen.
Der muss das mal abhorchen.
Dann kann es sein, dass man ein Medikament
braucht.
Ich musste meine
vorletzten Katze auch mal
Fieber messen.
Ich habe gedacht,
das wird nichts.
Das klappt
im Leben nicht.
Der Tierarzt hat gemeint,
wie jetzt Fieber messen?
Einfach mit dem Fieberthermometer.
Einfach Fieberthermometer.
Das ging tatsächlich
ganz gut.
Ich habe mich auf den Schoß gesetzt,
ein bisschen festgehalten
und Fieberthermometer in Poppes
ein Stückchen gemessen.
Katzen haben ja standardmäßig
eh ein bisschen höhere Temperatur.
Hat funktioniert.
Es war viel einfacher als gedacht.
Ich müsste das nicht
jeden Tag machen.
Das war für alle Beteiligten unangenehm.
Aber das geht.
Das hat ihr nicht gefallen.
Die hat da gesessen,
ganz normal auf dem Schoß.
Da hat sich nichts gedacht bei.
Als ich das Fieberthermometer
in Poppes gesteckt habe,
hast du richtig gemerkt.
Was ist das?
Das geht ja
schnell.
20 Sekunden ist das fertig.
Da hast du richtig der Katze angemerkt.
Was ist jetzt los?
Als ich fertig war, ist sie auch runter gehüpft.
Erstmal einen Schritt weg.
Aber die hat nichts gemacht.
Hat das über sich ergehen lassen.
So, fertig geworden.
Alles geklappt, so wie es sollte.
Perfekt.
Dann geht es wieder weiter in den Stall.
Der Unterschied ist zwischen ihm
und dieser
Excel
Schubser Projektmanagerin,
die sie da auch mal hatten.
Die habe ich mir gemerkt,
weil das so komplett entgegen dem war,
was ich mir so unter Arbeiten vorstelle.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Der steht einfach 5 Uhr auf und arbeitet
bis 18 Uhr oder so.
Die andere telefoniert dreimal am Tag
und erstellt zwei Excel-Tabellen.
Wie hieß das mit der Excel-Frau?
Irgendwas mit
Beraterin oder sowas?
Schauen wir mal nach Excel.
Projekt?
Hm.
Wie hieß denn das?
Berater?
Die hier.
Sales Training.
Selbstständig als Vertriebstrainerin.
Genau.
Die am Tag irgendwie zweimal telefoniert
und dreimal telefoniert
und zwei Excel-Tabellen erstellt hat.
Ich verdiene
brutto 1690 Euro.
Das ist ja bitter.
Das ist ja nichts.
Und dafür bist du
den ganzen Tag am Schaffen.
Das ist ja echt wenig.
Dass zumindest eine 2 vorne steht,
das ist wirklich wenig.
Für die Arbeit,
die das macht.
Netto sind dann raus
1439.
Das ist wirklich
nicht viel.
Relativ viel
netto übrig, da ich
ein Mitarbeitendes Familienmitglied bin.
Zum Glück muss er davon
nicht so viele Steuern bezahlen.
Trotzdem, 1400 Euro netto
ist echt nicht
so toll.
Und sozusagen
die Krankenbeiträge
und Pflegebeiträge
von meinem Vater,
vom Betrieb zu 100% abgehen.
Das ist natürlich ganz gut.
Ich bekomme 500 Euro Weihnachtsgeld.
Da kommt man dann
schlussendlich auf ein Jahresbrutto
von 20.780 Euro.
Mein Mindestlohn ist
glaube ich 1100 Euro
im Monat.
Da ist das schon mehr.
Aber trotzdem, es ist wirklich wenig.
Es ist echt wenig.
Ich würde woanders
mehr verdienen.
Wahrscheinlich auch
ein ganzes Stück mehr.
Aber woanders
würde ich wahrscheinlich keinen Betrieb
übernehmen können.
Na gut.
Ist halt die Frage, ob man das so rechnen kann.
Wenn ich mir das Recht überlege.
Ich meine,
das ist das, was er quasi als Monatsgehalt
kriegt. Aber nachdem das ein Familienbetrieb
ist, geht ja
irgendwie das, was er dort
verdient, also was
die Firma verdient, am
Jahresende,
zwar nicht direkt in seine Tasche, aber
potenziell in seine Tasche noch.
Es ist insgesamt
schon echt nicht viel. Vielleicht
scammt ihn der Vater. Man weiß nicht.
Würde ich jetzt aber mal nicht von
ausgehen. Kommt mal her.
Schau ein gutes Zeichen, dass es gleich aufsteht.
Jetzt hat es Hunger.
Du hast Hunger, komm.
Grumm, grumm, grumm.
Jawohl.
Moment, kann das trinken und
muhen gleichzeitig?
Hab ich das gerade richtig gesehen? Multitasking-Kalb?
Guck mal, das trinkt.
Oder das andere Mut?
Und das ist deine.
Perfekt.
So soll es sein.
Das stinkt bestimmt auch
übelst.
Ich laufe manchmal vorbei
an so einem, ja auch so
einem Betrieb, so was
in der Richtung. Die haben auch
Schweine, Kühe, Schafe
und so. Und da läufst
du manchmal vorbei und
je nach Tag liegt da halt
eins bis drei riesengroße Misthaufen.
Und wenn du da vorbei läufst,
da bin ich immer doppelt so
schnell wie sonst. Da stinkt
es immer. Wie sauber.
Und je nach Wind
kriegst du das quasi schon die halbe Strecke
ab. Ich wohne sozusagen
im Dachgeschoss in unserem Haus und bin
erst vor kurzem sogar fertig geworden mit dem Ausbauen.
Also ganz frisch.
Warst du nie
in den Bergen wandern?
Also das, was Schweizer und Österreicher
in den Bergen verstehen nehmen. Ausbauen,
Kredit aufgenommen, 6000 Euro.
Und die zahle ich jetzt monatlich über zwei Jahre
ab. Das Höchste bei uns
ist 450 Meter.
Genau.
Mein Hobby ist das Enduro
und Motocross fahren
und es ist schon sehr, sehr teuer.
5500 Euro habe ich damals
bezahlt, 2017.
Das kannst du ja sogar fast schon für ein Fahrrad
ausgeben heute.
Ich habe es mal zusammengerechnet, glaube
8.000 bis 9.000 Euro reingesteckt
an Ersatzteile,
Reparaturen, pipapo.
Das war vielleicht nicht die vernünftigste
Investition, aber eine gute.
Jetzt kann er über den eigenen Acker heizen
damit.
Eigentlich auch nice.
Bisschen angegeben im Wheelie.
Für mich lohnt es sich auf jeden Fall.
Es ist einfach der schönste Beruf,
den man sich vorstellen kann und ich mache
ihn jeden Tag gerne.
Oh nein, nein, nein, nein, Tors, Tors, Tors,
Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors,
Tors, Tors, Tors.
Ich meine,
er schwimmt nicht im Geld, aber letztendlich
ist es auch egal, solange er happy ist.
Dann könnt ihr das doch auch tun.
Und hier kommt ihr noch zu weiteren
Videos, zum Beispiel zum Metzgermeister
oder zu anderen Videos.
Metzgermeister,
den haben wir auch noch nicht geguckt.
Mal gucken wir jetzt auch nicht, was anderes.
Welches davon?
Was mein Kumpel macht, sein Land
wird betriebdicht, macht damit einfach keine
Kohle mehr. Ich stelle es mir schwierig
vor in Deutschland.
Sowas, sagen wir mal,
langfristig irgendwie vertretbar
und ordentlich Kohle
zu betreiben.
Ja, das sieht er bestimmt anders.
Für mich wäre das auch nichts.
Für mich wäre das viel zu viel
Natur und Stinke-Zeug
und alles, aber
das sind die Leute halt
unterschiedlich.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir in absehbarer Zeit
keine Kuhmilch mehr brauchen.
Natur ist richtig Dance-Game.
Einzige Mal
Natur ist ganz gut, wenn ich irgendwie mal ein bisschen
rumlaufen will draußen.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Was ist das denn für eine Playlist?
Das ist Beachside
Holiday Nintendo Summer Music Mix
Was haben wir denn hier?
WhatsApp
Oh, ist das
ist das diesmal ein anderer?
Ist das
nicht der liebe Hackerinnen und
Hacker?
WhatsApp wird für Telegram, Signal
und Co. geöffnet.
Aha, dann gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, wie Lukas das
macht.
Guck mal hier, das bin ich, wie ich
versuche, mit Signal Leuten auf WhatsApp
zu schreiben. Und Überraschung,
klappt nicht. Könnte es aber, wenn es
nach der EU geht.
Ach so, die wollen sie da
Na, ob das was wird?
Und ihr denkt euch jetzt bestimmt, ja cool, aber
wo ist Kino? Ja, der ist leider
krank und deswegen übernehme ich die Woche 2003.
Also, schau mal hier.
Das ist der Digital Markets Act der EU.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, boah, hören wir
mit dem langweiligen Scheiß auf?
Dann sind wir eigentlich einer Meinung.
Das ist nämlich wirklich alles andere als spannend,
so 100 Seiten Gesetzestext
durchzulesen. Haben wir aber trotzdem mal
gemacht. Warum? Wetten, dass selbst die Leute,
die darüber abstimmen, die 100
Seiten nicht gelesen haben,
nicht mal ansatzweise, die haben irgendeinen
Dude, der das für sie zusammengefasst hat.
Je nachdem, wie gut er das gemacht hat, wissen sie Bescheid oder nicht.
Weil die EU da
ganz schön viele Dinge regelt, die unseren
digitalen Alltag krass verändern könnten.
Das neue iPhone zum Beispiel
hat jetzt unter anderem wegen der EU
USB-C, also wie jedes
anderes. Aber war das nicht so?
Mit Kack-Datenübertragung mit USB-C?
Apple muss auf seinen iPhones
Zeitloading, also das Installieren von
Apps außerhalb des App-Stores erlauben
und WhatsApp. Moment, Moment.
Das geht doch die ganze Zeit schon.
Zeitloading. Aber das Problem
ist, dass diese Apps sich
nach sieben Tagen oder so automatisch wieder
aninstallen.
Also, wenn die das anpassen, wäre
das extrem nice.
Das wäre richtig
gut. Aber wahrscheinlich
wird das wieder irgendeinen Haken haben
bei Apple.
Das Installieren von Apps außerhalb des App-Stores
erlauben und WhatsApp muss
bald mit allen Messengern kompatibel werden.
Denn wenn es nach der EU geht,
dann müssen bald alle großen Messenger-Anbieter
miteinander funktionieren.
Interoperabilität heißt das.
Das wird
wahrscheinlich so
umgesetzt, dass es am Ende
keiner benutzen will.
So nach dem Motto
Plaintext only, 140
Zeichen und unverschlüsselt.
So nach dem Motto.
Vielleicht besser klingt, als es dann wirklich ist.
Bleibt dran. Liebe Hackerin,
liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen
hier bei
Keine Sonderzeichen. Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von Yonnas. Seit über 25
Jahren ist Yonnas im Hosting-Geschäft
unterwegs. War das nicht 1&1?
Ein Digitalisierungspartner. 10 Rechenzentren
in 5 Ländern mit 100.000
Servern hat... Chat!
Was ist mit euch los?
Keck, wait! Da hat jemand
beim USB-Standard nicht aufgepasst.
Was soll das? Das ist nicht USB 3.0.
Das ist
USB 4.0
Gen 3.2
3x1 X4
oder sowas.
Wie kannst du sagen,
das ist USB 3.0?
Anzeige ist raus. Ich schicke es
direkt an das USB-Konsortium.
Gremium.
Und dann darfst du nie wieder im Leben
USB verwenden.
Gut, dass wir das jetzt geklärt haben.
Also um ganz
korrekt zu sein, heißt das jetzt...
Moment.
Um ganz korrekt
zu sein, heißt das jetzt...
Heißt das jetzt...
Äh...
Ich blicke mit der Tabelle
nicht durch. Ja, das ist gut.
USB
3.2
Gen 1x1
heißt das jetzt.
Okay? Bitteschön.
Und es wird noch viel geiler,
wenn es ganze USB
4V2 gibt.
Das ist so
dämlich.
Ich meine,
warum nicht 4.0 und 4.1,
please?
Und dann gibt es
USB 4.2.0
und es gibt auch noch
USB 2.0. Das ist so
dämlich, Alter.
Ich kann es mir auch nicht anders vorstellen,
als dass das Absicht ist.
Da klingt einfach USB 3.2
neuer als USB 4.
Also, die korrekte Bezeichnung
heutzutage wäre, um das jetzt noch mal
abzuschließen,
die korrekte Bezeichnung wäre
heutzutage USB 3.2 Gen 1x1.
Oder alternativ
Super Speed USB.
Ja, und da findet ihr
ziemlich sicher genau das, was ihr braucht.
Zum Beispiel in Sachen VPS, natürlich
auch mit ordentlich GPU-Power.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Fallen wir mal auf die Werbung rein.
Lasst uns mal gucken.
Achtung, Flashbang. Boah, meine Augen.
Was kostet hier?
Domain, Hosting, Wordpress, Cloud Computing.
Products.
Compute Engine.
Wisst ihr, eine Zeit lang hieß das einfach mal VM,
aber Compute Engine klingt natürlich einfach
viel geiler.
View Prices.
Gibt es sowas wie
Shared Core oder so?
Okay, wir kriegen...
Hä?
Kann ich nicht einfach mal was anklicken?
Eine ordentliche Tabelle.
Was kostet jetzt?
Okay.
Hier.
Zwei CPUs,
8GB RAM
und ein bisschen SSD wahrscheinlich.
Kostet...
Ähm...
11 Cent
oder 12 Cent die Stunde.
Also mal 24.
Am Tag.
Mal, ja, keine Ahnung, 30.
What?
Das ist
übelst ultra...
Habe ich mich verrechnet?
Habe ich mich
irgendwie verrechnet?
Das ist abfuck megas teuer.
Muss man vielleicht ein Komma dazwischen machen?
Mal 24?
Ne.
Also es kostet ungefähr
3 Euro am Tag.
Boah, das ist
ultra teuer. Alter, was sind
das für Preise?
Ich meine, vergleichen wir das mal
beispielsweise. Das kostet ja
bei Google weniger.
Ich habe doch
jetzt irgendwas übersehen, oder?
Mach mal mal 720
für den Monat.
Du meinst das hier?
Ja, ist genau das gleiche.
Ja.
Ich meine,
habe ich vielleicht das falsche Produkt mir angeguckt?
Ja, weil ich meine,
guck mal,
bei Hetzner
kriegst du eine kleine Kiste,
ähnliche Ausstattung für 14 Euro
im Monat.
Und das ist auch ganz schön teuer geworden,
ne? Animond, das ist dedicated.
Okay, ja. Ich wollte gerade sagen,
also
da kriegst du teilweise
Sachen für unter 10 Euro.
Also
das ist teuer.
Bin ich
verkehrt?
Ionos Server, bin ich verkehrt?
Ist Compute Engine keine VM?
Hm.
Ach hier, Servers gibt es auch noch.
Und dann haben wir noch
Cloud Servers.
Okay, das ist wieder so undurchsichtig.
Undurchsichtiges Ding.
Choose
Data Center, Frankfurt.
Ja,
das sind doch schon angenehmere Preise.
Damit
kann man doch leben.
Das ist doch okay.
4 CPUs, 8G, 240G,
SSD. Ich hoffe es ist SSD, ja.
Aber kostet später.
Also das sind Preise, die sind okay.
Aber jetzt mal,
ist das der Vorteil von der Compute Instance?
Ist das Shared CPU?
Oder wie?
Ich verstehe so nicht den Unterschied,
warum ich das andere kaufen sollte.
Na gut.
Wie auch immer, irgendein
MonkaS, ja ja.
Irgendeinen Sinn wird es schon haben.
Und wenn es ein Unsinn ist, hat mein Opa jetzt gesagt.
Das war so ein Cringe-Spruch von ihm.
Den hat er laufend gebracht, wenn irgendwas war,
was ihm nicht gefällt.
Aber er hat keinen Bock dazu
zu begründen, was ihm nicht gefällt.
Ja, das ist Ultra-Boomer.
Aber ich meine, das war mein Opa.
Mein Opa war noch Pre-Boomer.
Die gab es noch gar nicht.
Mein Opa hat die Boomer-Generation mit auf die Welt gebracht.
Sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben?
Der malende Opa.
Ja, ich habe nur einen Opa.
Also ich habe theoretisch natürlich auch
einen zweiten Opa, aber ich glaube, den kenne ich nicht.
Vielleicht war mir der irgendwann mal, wo ich klein war,
aber keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne nur eine Oma und nur einen Opa.
Gar nicht, erstmal.
Wir haben nichts mehr abgesprochen in letzter Zeit.
Ich mache auch gerade ein bisschen wenig
Gestrimse und so. Das passt gerade nicht.
Denkst du, eine Ausbildung
zum Physi bei einem großen
Telekommunikationsunternehmen,
welches einen magenten Hintergrund auf dem Logo hat,
ist eine gute Entscheidung?
Ja, denke ich.
Ne, Offline-Events, kein Bock.
Ionos, Terraform, ja.
Die haben einen eigenen Terraform-Provider.
Es hat so ziemlich jeder Cloud-Anbieter,
der was auf sich hält, einen eigenen Terraform-Anbieter.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel KI-Anwendungen
machen wollt. Und einen Cloud-Anbieter, der keinen
Terraform-Provider hat, den kannst du halt nicht benutzen.
Deswegen gibt es die halt auch immer
weniger. Bei Ionos, ihr bekommt
24-7 echten technischen
Support mit dedizierten Ansprechpartnern.
Guck mal, da ruft dich dein Dr. Best an
oder sowas und sagt, dein Server
hat hohe CPU-Last. Ionos, ihr bekommt
24-7 echten technischen
Support mit dedizierten Ansprechpartnern.
Schaut doch mal rein auf www.ionos.de.
Erbung Ende.
Joa, der Messenger-Markt
ist also an dem Punkt angekommen, wo
sich die Politik gezwungen sieht, einzugreifen.
Schon krass. Denn früher
war das eigentlich schon mal besser gelöst.
Ganz Oldschool kann man das seit fast
30 Jahren jeden mit nem Handy
erreichen. Ein Nokia-Communicator!
Sowas hab ich damals,
hab ich damals, als ich beim Provider gearbeitet hab, auch bekommen.
Das war noch Pre-iPhone.
Nokia-Communicator.
Das war richtig reudig, das Ding.
Am 3. Dezember 1992
hat der Ingenieur Neil Pebworth
die allererste SMS der Welt
verschickt. Kurz und knapp hat er
darin einem Kollegen Merry Christmas
gewünscht. Joa, und dann ging es so richtig
los. Die SMS wurde der
Verkaufsschlager der Mobilfunkanbieter.
Bis zu 39 Cent haben Kunden
früher für eine SMS mit 140
Zeichen... SMS sind heute immer noch
übelst teuer.
Richtig unsinnig teuer.
... wurden alleine in Deutschland noch
über 59 Milliarden SMS
verschickt. Der Erfolg der SMS kam,
wie bei der E-Mail auch, weil es einen
einheitlichen Standard gibt, den jeder
benutzt. Jeder kann einfach jeden
erreichen. Egal ob Sony, Ericsson...
Aber Leute, Leute, Leute, ernsthaft.
Wenn Telegram und Signal und so
und WhatsApp miteinander reden können,
iMessage fällt doch bestimmt
wieder raus, oder?
iMessage wird doch... Apple macht doch
bestimmt nicht mit...
Rola, LG oder Nokia Handy.
Man musste sich also keine Gedanken
machen, welche Plattform der andere benutzt.
Ja, und diesen kostenpflichtigen
Luxus, den haben uns die ganzen Messaging
Anbieter dann wieder genommen.
Weil heute viele auf WhatsApp schreiben,
andere auf Signal, manche auf Telegram
und dann gibt es noch Streamer oder
iMessage, you name it. Also es gibt
Messenger-Anbieter wie Sand am Meer.
Und die sind fast alle gratis und
können auch mehr als diese Oldschool-SMS.
Aber das hat einen entscheidenden
Nachteil. Wenn ich mit jemandem schreiben
möchte, der nicht den gleichen Anbieter wie
ich hat, dann muss einer von uns beiden
halt wohl oder übel einen neuen Messenger
installieren. Das ist natürlich mega
nervig und kundenunfreundlich
für uns Verbraucher und deswegen
möchte die EU jetzt große Anbieter
dazu zwingen, dass sie miteinander funktionieren.
Und deswegen gilt seit Mai
2023 der Digital
Markets Act, also das Gesetz über
digitale Märkte. Und das besagt
groß. Bin ich mal gespannt, wie sie
sich da drum rumwinden wollen.
Anbieter, also sogenannte
Gatekeeper, müssen ihre Angebote
für andere Anbieter auf deren
Verlangen zugänglich machen. Oder
einfach gesagt, WhatsApp muss es zum
Beispiel wire ermöglichen, Nachrichten
mit WhatsApp auszutauschen. Als solche
Gatekeeper zählen für die EU
Anbieter, die zum einen mehr
als 45 Millionen monatlich aktive
Ich finde es vom Ansatz her eigentlich
nicht schlecht. Aktive Nutzer in der
EU haben, die in mehr als drei
EU-Ländern ihre Dienste anbieten und die
in den letzten drei Jahren mindestens
7,5 Milliarden Euro Umsatz
erzielt haben. Die EU hat jetzt
offiziell mitgeteilt, welche Anbieter
unter diese Regelung fallen werden. Das
sind Alphabet, also Google, Amazon,
Apple, ByteDance, also TikTok
Apple bedeutet auch iMessage
und Microsoft. Für das
Messaging bedeutet das aber, dass
nur Meta, also WhatsApp und der
Facebook Messenger unter diese Regelung fallen.
iMessage wird zwar gerade noch geprüft,
aber laut Apple hat der Dienst
weniger als 45 Millionen
monatlich aktive Nutzer in der EU
und würde deswegen gar nicht unter diese Regelung fallen.
Und jetzt hat Meta eben
sechs
Monate Zeit,
diese Regelungen umzusetzen und
die beiden Dienste auf das Verlangen von anderen
Anbietern hin zu öffnen. Erstmal
nur für Einzelchats, innerhalb von zwei
Jahren dann auch für Gruppenchats und noch mal
später dann auch für Videoanrufe und
ganz normale Anrufe. Vor ein paar Tagen sind
schon Screenshots von einem WhatsApp Update
rumgegangen, die ein Chatfenster für
Drittanbieterchats zeigen.
Und heißt das jetzt, der Lukas vom Anfang aus
diesem Video kann dann einfach mit Signal
all seine Kontakte erreichen? Nein.
Denn auch wenn Meta jetzt von der EU
gezwungen wird, ihre Dienste zu öffnen,
die kleinen Anbieter müssen da halt auch
mitmachen wollen. Und ich sag mal so,
wenn ich jetzt als Nutzer zu einem kleineren Anbieter
wie Threema gehen würde,
damit meine Daten gerade nicht bei Meta
landen, dann fände ich es nicht so nice,
wenn die auf einmal eine Schnittstelle zu Meta,
also zu WhatsApp oder dem Facebook Messenger
anbieten würden. Signal hat deswegen auch schon
länger angekündigt, dass sie bei dieser ganzen
Interoperabilität nicht mitmachen
wollen und weil Signal eben kein Gatekeeper
ist, kann sie die EU auch nicht
dazu zwingen. Genauso wie Threema
übrigens, die auch schon angekündigt haben,
dass sie sich bei diesem Thema erstmal zurückhalten
müssen. Das Problem ist, neben der
Sorge um die Nutzerdaten, die dann bei Meta
landen, auch, dass dann genau das
Gegenteil passieren könnte. Also kleinere
Anbieter befürchten, dass am Ende
eher weniger Nutzer auf ihre Plattform
kommen, wenn die auch von WhatsApp aus
erreichbar wären. Es könnte,
stand jetzt, also tatsächlich passieren, dass
Facebook Messenger und WhatsApp
Drittanbieterchats zwar ermöglichen,
dass aber niemand in Anspruch nimmt.
Was aber wirklich nochmal Bewegung in
dieses Interoperabilitätsthema
bringen könnte, wäre, wenn die EU
iMessage zu einem Gatekeeper
erklären würde. Sollte Apple iMessage
öffnen müssen, wäre das nämlich
tatsächlich eine krasse Veränderung.
In den USA sind iPhones deutlich
verbreiteter als hier bei uns und damit
ist iMessage weltweit einer der
beliebtesten Messaging-Anbieter, der
aber nur auf iPhones funktioniert.
Kontakte ohne iPhone bekommen dann
einfach eine normale SMS zugeschickt.
Und der Chat hat dann eine grüne statt einer blauen
Sprechblase. Was bedeutet,
diese Textnachricht war jetzt vielleicht
kostenpflichtig. Auf jeden Fall nicht
kostenlos über das Internet übertragen,
sondern ganz oldschool eine SMS.
Und damit hält Apple auch wirklich
Leute bei iMessage und dem iPhone,
weil sie ihre Blue Bubbles nicht verlieren
wollen. Und in Deutschland könnten
iPhone-Nutzer dann einfach aus der Nachrichten-
App heraus mit WhatsApp-Kontakten
chatten und eben andersrum.
Und sollte iMessage wirklich als Gatekeeper
benannt werden, dann müssten sie auch
mitmachen. Die Strafen, wenn sich Unternehmen
nicht daran halten, sind nämlich
super hoch. Bis zu 10%
vom weltweiten Gesamtumsatz und bei
wiederholter Zuwiderhandlung sogar bis
zu 20%. Technisch
ist die Interoperabilität wohl über
ein neues gemeinsames Protokoll umgesetzt,
das auch verschlüsselt. Denn
bisher verwenden Messenger wie WhatsApp
teilweise unterschiedliche Protokolle,
die sie selbst entwickelt haben.
Das ist natürlich heftig.
Was magst du von Serenity als Community-Round-Table?
Nee, heute nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, nee, nee, nee.
Nicht mit anderen kompatibel sind.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich einer der größten
Schwerpunkte an der ganzen Geschichte, weil
das Zusammenführen von Konversationen
zwischen verschiedenen Anbietern nicht
einfach mit dem Umlegen von dem Hebel
funktioniert. Es braucht also eine Möglichkeit,
um zwischen den verschiedenen Messengern
die Interoperabilität anbieten,
zu vermitteln. Eine Lösung dafür
könnte das Messaging Layer Security
Protokoll sein, kurz MLS.
Damit soll zukünftig sichere
Kommunikation mit Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung
auch in Gruppen möglich sein.
Meta hat bei der Entwicklung übrigens
mitgewirkt, genauso wie Google, Mozilla
oder AWS. Damit gäbe es
dann einen einheitlichen Standard zur Verschlüsselung
und der könnte auch von kleineren Anbietern
...
AWS ist auch so ein dummes Wort, weil
jeder auf der Welt spricht es sinnvoll
aus, nur die Amis nicht.
...genutzt werden, wenn sie denn
...englischsprachige Länder
...ist die Frage, wie sich
Nutzer in unterschiedlichen Plattformen
denn eigentlich finden können. Und
was mit Nutzern ist, die ihre Nummer schon für
...W ist so ein unglaublich
dummer Buchstabe ...
könnten die dann einen Standarddienst zum Beispiel
angeben. Joa, ist noch ein bisschen was zu
tun in den nächsten 6 Monaten, sag ich mal.
Mein Fazit. Also in der Theorie ist
das, was die EU davor hat, auf jeden Fall
erst mal gut. Denn große Monopole
führen über einen längeren Zeitraum bei den
Usern eigentlich nie zu mehr
Zufriedenheit. Also, dass die EU jetzt
zum Beispiel Apple vorschreibt, dass sie auf den
iPhones auch Apps erlauben müssen, die nicht
aus dem App Store kommen, richtig gut.
Aber ich wage mal zu bezweifeln,
ob sich durch diese Änderungen bei den Messengern
jetzt ernsthaft was verändert.
Weil die EU kann Meta noch so sehr
zwingen, seine Pforten zu öffnen, wenn
kein anderer Anbieter Bock hat, dann bleibt
halt alles so, wie es ist. Also,
wenn man wirklich für jeden erreichbar sein möchte
und auch jeden erreichen möchte, dann
bleibt einem wahrscheinlich auch in Zukunft
nichts anderes übrig, als mehrere
Messenger-Dienste auf seinem Smartphone zu installieren.
Das machen aber wieder nur wenige
und so beißt sich die Katze dann irgendwie
wieder in den Schwanz. Und am Ende ist es
dann einfach wieder das leichteste, einfach
auf WhatsApp zu sein, weil da sind im
Zweifel halt alle. Wie seht ihr das?
Nutzt ihr einen anderen Messenger als
WhatsApp und würdet ihr euch wünschen, damit
auch an WhatsApp-Nutzer Nachrichten schreiben zu können?
Also, ich fände es cool, von iMessage aus
an WhatsApp zum Beispiel schreiben zu können.
Schreibt es gerne mal in die Kommentare. Das wäre nice.
Der Rest interessiert mich nicht. Und natürlich auch gerne
abonnieren. Tschüss.
Wäre, wäre nice.
Also, wenn, ups.
Wenn das funktioniert, wäre wirklich, wäre wirklich
extrem, extremely hog.
Oder was denkt ihr? Also
iMessage fände ich, fände ich nice.
Der Rest interessiert mich jetzt persönlich nicht so.
Ich meine,
es gab ja früher schon mal so,
so was ähnliches.
Es gab ja früher Multi-Messenger.
So Pidgin oder
was gab's da sonst noch?
Ihr wisst, ihr wisst, was ich meine. Kennt das noch irgendjemand?
Kennt auch jemand
Pidgin Messenger?
Kennst du die Videos?
Ja, kenn ich.
Kennt das Ding noch jemand?
Pidgin?
Konntest du ICQ mitmachen?
Jabber, AOL
und alles mögliche.
Und da gab
es auch schon Verschlüsselungs-Plugins
für, die auf
Plaintext-Kommunikation aufgesetzt
haben. Da gab es dann zum Beispiel OTR.
Und das konntest du
über
alle Messenger gleichermaßen
machen, war trotzdem verschlüsselt.
Der Messenger selbst hat dann, es war halt kleinseitig
verschlüsselt, hat dann
nur noch gesehen,
dass halt verschlüsselt
übertragen wurde.
Das war eigentlich ganz cool.
Etwas outdated heutzutage, ja.
Wir sollten bald den
Universal-Champ entwickeln. Der kann einfach,
der vereint alle Champs.
Der Meta-Champ.
Programmierer reagiert auf
Zuschauer-Apps.
Wir könnten auf den
Programmierer reagieren, der auf Zuschauer-Apps
reagiert.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? 30...
Der Auer!
Haben wir lange nichts mehr geguckt.
30 Jahre altes Tool
soll CPUs vor Überhitzung schützen.
Okay, mal gucken.
Der Auer.
Hallo zusammen,
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem weiteren Video.
Ich hab mal wieder was Verrücktes ausgegraben.
Und zwar das SystoTec.
Und das ist ein Tool,
das ist fast 30 Jahre alt. Das schauen wir uns
gleich natürlich noch genauer an.
Und das sollte
verhindern anscheinend, dass die
CPU überhitzt.
Aber ich hab mir das angeschaut und hab da so ein bisschen
meine Zweifel, ob das Ding
überhaupt funktionieren kann.
Das schauen wir uns im heutigen Video an.
Das heutige Video wird unterstützt von Corsair mit dem
neuen 2000D Mini-ITX-Gehäuse.
Ich hab selbst vor einigen Wochen
Da muss ich echt sagen,
das finde ich schick, das Case.
Also wenn man gern
so ein Ding auf dem Schreibtisch stehen hat,
sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Lautsprecher.
Find ich nicht auch.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein alter Lautsprecher.
System in dem Gehäuse gebaut für Corsair Deutschland.
Und muss sagen, war sehr zufrieden mit
den Montagemöglichkeiten von
360° AIO und auch langen Grafikkarten
bis 365mm.
Auch SFX-L Netzteile mit bis
zu 1000 Watt lassen sich wirklich problemlos
Moment, das fängt doch total viel
Staub, oder? Wenn es daneben offen ist.
Dieses kleine System verbauen.
Ich verlinke euch mal unten das Gehäuse und vor allem auch
mein Video bei Corsair Deutschland.
Da könnt ihr euch einfach mal anschauen, wie ich dieses System
gebaut habe. Schaut euch das gerne nach diesem Video
mal an. So sieht das Gerät aus.
Sysotec CPU
Fan Failure und Thermal
Over 110°C
Warning Device.
Und ich hab mir gerade so gedacht,
was zur Hölle soll das eigentlich sein?
Auf den ersten Blick,
hier oben kommt erstmal Strom
Übertakter ist der Lüfter, oder was?
Da steht Current Power und hier unten
steht Current Fan Plug.
Ist das ein Lüftungsübertakter?
Im Prinzip einfach nur zwischen
die CPU
486 DX Pentium und Pentium Pro
Okay, damals war halt,
damals konnte der CPU auch noch kühlen,
wenn du drauf gepustet hast.
Lüfter, Stromversorgung geschaltet werden.
Wir sehen hier CPU und Fan
und da soll das einfach nur dazwischen
und dann soll das irgendwie
ich weiß nicht genau wie
uns davor bewahren, dass die
CPU 110°C
warm wird, wie man hier oben sehen
kann.
Kleines Detail, hier unten steht
486 DX Pentium
und Pentium Pro Systems.
Wenn wir uns einfach nur die CPUs anschauen,
also 486 DX, den gab es ja von
AMD und auch Intel,
dann Intel Pentium und Pentium Pro.
Die CPUs sind von einem Zeitraum von
1994-1995, das heißt
das Ding hier ist wahrscheinlich um die 28 Jahre alt.
Es hat also ein paar Jährchen auf dem Buckel.
Ist auf jeden Fall cool, dass es noch
neu und original verpackt ist.
Wenn man sich allerdings zum Beispiel
so einen 486 hier anschaut,
den Pentium oder Pentium Pro, dann wird man
feststellen, dass diese CPUs
nicht über 85°C laufen können.
Und wenn man dann sieht,
dass das die CPU vor 110°C
beschützen soll, dann bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher,
wie zur Hölle das eigentlich funktionieren soll.
Das werden wir dann vielleicht gleich rausfinden,
wenn wir uns das Ding im Detail anschauen.
Ansonsten seht ihr hier hinten,
PE Logic ist der Hersteller, die bewerben
hier alles mögliche mit Connections
...
Was soll ich machen, wenn mein Laptop hängt und so Geräusche
macht und ich nichts drücken oder mit Tasche...
Wenn der Laptop Geräusche macht,
das kann ja meistens nur
an irgendeinem Lüfter liegen,
da wirst du wahrscheinlich aufschrauben müssen.
Du könntest auch mal versuchen,
durchzupusten mit
so einer Druckluftflasche,
so einem Druckluftspray,
wenn du sowas hast.
Aber wahrscheinlich
wirst du den aufmachen müssen.
Zu SCSI,
aka SCSI, das heißt,
der alte, lange Anschluss,
den kennen vielleicht die ein oder anderen von euch noch,
den man mal früher an dem PC hatte.
Und dann bin ich auf die Webseite von
PE Logic gegangen, beziehungsweise ich wollte,
musste feststellen, die gibt es nicht mehr. Welche Überraschung.
Hab dann die Wayback Machine verwendet
und hab dann gesehen, dass es PE Logic seit dem
Jahr 2000 schon nicht mehr gibt.
Schon wirklich, wirklich lange.
Die haben also nicht lange überlebt. Liegt vielleicht daran,
weil dieses Produkt vielleicht gar keinen Sinn macht,
was wir noch rausfinden müssen.
Ansonsten hab ich dann noch versucht, den einen oder anderen
Spot von Wayback Machine,
von dieser Firma hier,
zu öffnen und musste dann feststellen,
dass man zu diesem Teil hier einfach nichts
findet. Also wirklich rein gar nichts. Das heißt,
ich hab keinerlei Ahnung, was sie sich dabei gedacht
haben, wie zur Hölle dieses Ding
feststellen möchte,
ob die CPU 110°C warm wurde.
Auf der Verpackung haben wir noch den
einen oder anderen Hinweis. Ich bin mir immer noch nicht
ganz sicher, wie das funktionieren soll. Denn hier
steht zum Beispiel, emits a piercing sound,
when CPU fan fails or system overheats.
Das heißt, hier steht dran, dass
dieses Teil... Das müsst ihr aber irgendwie
erst mal messen können, wie warm die CPU
überhaupt ist. Es hat überhaupt keine Probe oder so dran.
...ein schönes Geräusch erzeugen soll,
wenn der CPU-Lüfter
nicht mehr funktioniert oder das
System überhitzt.
Wie genau das funktionieren soll, dass der
merkt, dass die CPU überhitzt, ist mir einfach
nicht ganz klar. Ja, mir auch nicht.
Irgendeine Kommunikation mit der CPU
stattfinden. Aber vielleicht ist da irgendwas dran,
was ich noch nicht verstanden hab oder gesehen habe.
Ansonsten gibt es hier immer noch
viel Werbung an der Seite, was alles passieren kann.
Schlimmes, wenn euer CPU-Lüfter
ausfällt bei den
Highspeed-Computern. Made in USA.
486.
Und was da alles passieren kann.
Und hier steht dann eben einfach, wenn der Lüfter
ausfällt, dann hilft euch SystoTec
mit dem Ton. Und dann soll man
den Lüfter wechseln und dann
hilft SystoTec wieder, das System zu
überwachen. Wie genau, ist mir ehrlich gesagt
ein absolutes Rätsel.
Sieht ein bisschen aus, wie so ein
Dongle, den man heute an den Bus da
im Auto stecken kann.
Also erstmal haben wir hier...
Wisst ihr, was ich meine? Gibt ja für Autos
so Sachen zum Auslesen, die sehen ein bisschen
so ähnlich aus. Ein Sticker
unter dem Gerät und da steht
dran, dass man diesen Sticker am
Gehäuse, am System anbringen soll,
dass wenn dieser Warnton
ertönt, dann überhitzt das
System auf jeden Fall und man muss irgendwie
den Lüfter tauschen. Okay.
Hier haben wir unsere magische, ich will nicht
sagen Blackbox, weil das ist transparent.
Aber wir haben nur
ein Molex für Power und ein Molex raus
für den Lüfter. Hier hinten,
da sollte der kleine Speaker sein.
Hier ist noch ein kleiner Ausschnitt drin. Warum bin ich mir nicht so
ganz sicher? Das könnte ein Temperatur...
Ließ erstmal ein CPU-Lüfter heute über Molex an.
...so sein. Ich schau mal, ob ich das öffnen
kann. Vielleicht wären wir da schlauer.
Ich werde da ehrlich gesagt auch nicht ganz schlau
draus. Also das in der Mitte ist auf jeden Fall ein Komparator.
Also der vergleicht einfach zwei Spannungen,
vielleicht die Eingangs-Ausgangs-Spannung vergleichen.
Also dieses Ding, wo dieses LM339 draufsteht
und der kleine IC,
der unter dem Fenster war. Da steht
T4C drauf. Könnte alles mögliche sein
und von dem, was ich gefunden habe,
ist das einfach nur ein Voltage-Detektor.
Also der sieht einfach auch nur,
ob eine Spannung anliegt oder nicht.
Wie wir gesehen haben, hat dieses
Ding ja Molex-Ein- und Ausgang.
Sondern nicht viel kann das Ding ja nicht machen.
Irgendein Chip da drauf, irgendwas mit Logik ist
ja da nicht drauf. Ich kann nicht einfach irgendeinen Lüfter
einschließen, einen aktuellen CPU-Kühler.
Weil heutzutage haben wir eigentlich immer
4-Pin-PWM oder im schlechten Fall
den 3-Pin-Stecker.
Aber das passt ja alles nicht dahin.
Und da kommt der gute, alte, cooler
Master-Jet-CPU-Kühler
ins Spiel. Das ist
so ein richtiger Klassiker von damals
und wie ihr sehen könnt, hat der auch
den Molex-Stromanschluss auch mit
zwei Kabeln, so wie das hier auf der
Verpackung zu sehen ist.
Wir haben zwar noch die Möglichkeit, hier irgendwas, glaube ich,
einzustellen. Das können wir gleich noch probieren.
Aber das hier wirklich
Klassiker der CPU-Kühler-Geschichte.
Und da sieht man, das ist
wirklich aufgebaut, soll so ein bisschen an so ein
Flugzeug-Jet-Antrieb
Turbinen-mäßig angelehnt sein.
Ich habe das Ding schon ewig nicht mehr
benutzt und ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht erinnern,
ob das Teil auch so laut war wie eine Turbine.
Das werden wir mal sehen.
Na da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Also der Kühler ist da.
Ich meine, es sieht schon mal
irgendwie cool aus, ne?
Top funktionieren bei so einem 12900K
oder vielleicht auch nicht, werden sehen.
Und wie ihr sehen könnt, natürlich, der Sticker ist auch
angebracht. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Ding der aktuelle CPU
gescheit kühlen kann.
Interessant, dass er den da
überhaupt gemountet bekommen hat, irgendwie, oder?
Beschrieben.
Jetzt starten wir das Ding und schauen, was passiert.
Oh, die Katze.
Das irritiert schon.
Äh, schick.
Der kleine Piepser schien mir
nicht so katzenfreundlich zu sein, deswegen musste ich
jetzt schick leider das mal von ihrem Platz vertreiben.
Der Cooler Master Jet
CPU-Kühler macht seinem Namen auch alle Ehre.
Das Ding ist ja...
Was haben die sich damals gedacht bei den
Kühlern, ja? Aber, witzig,
ihr hört, also ihr hört den Kühler,
aber ihr hört nicht mehr das nervige
Piepen.
Das lag nämlich daran, weil der
Kühler ein bisschen runtergedreht war von der Leistung.
Das können wir jetzt mal kurz machen an diesem Potentiometer hier.
Oh!
Also, wenn er nicht ganz runtergedreht ist,
das ist irgendwie ganz geil. Moment, das Ding guckt
einfach, wie viel der angeschlossene Lüfter
verbraucht, oder was?
Und daran will es irgendwie erkennen, wenn der
kaputt ist. Ja, weil dann fängt es so ein bisschen an zu kratzen,
wie so ein Walkie-Talk, ne?
Und wenn man es runterdreht, dann
rastet er komplett aus. Ist natürlich ein super
Design, ne? Super Idee, dass man
den Lüfter immer auf 100% betreiben
muss und ansonsten rastet dieses Ding komplett aus.
Tolle Idee. Nach wie vor,
also es scheint
zu funktionieren, dass wenn der
Lüfter nicht läuft, oder wir können ja mal
gucken, kann ich den anhalten?
Ah ja. Immerhin, immerhin.
Also theoretisch würde der Lüfter blockieren,
dann würde man ein Warnsignal
bekommen, dass der Lüfter nicht läuft.
Das ist schon mal gar nicht so schlecht.
Die Frage, die man sich stellen muss, ist, ist das
ein Szenario, das tatsächlich in der Realität
existiert? Ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
ob das mir jemals ein Lüfter kaputtgegangen ist.
Die Teile scheinen generell
endlos zu halten.
Da könnt ihr mir mal gerne in die Kommentare...
Doch, da muss ich sagen, mir ist schon
ein Lüfter kaputtgegangen, aber noch nie
ein CPU-Lüfter. Mir ist ein Lüfter
auf dem Mainboard kaputtgegangen bei meinem
Athlon XP damals.
War das ein Asus-Mainboard?
Und
der Lüfter hat irgendwann angefangen, tatsächlich
auch...
zu machen
und wollte dann nicht mehr.
Das war aber wirklich der einzige,
an den ich mich erinnern kann.
...schreiben, ob euch schon mal ein
Lüfter kaputtgegangen ist.
Das hatte ich tatsächlich noch nie.
Ich hatte es, glaube ich, einmal, dass ein Lüfter von
Anfang an nicht funktioniert hat, aber ansonsten
hatte ich das nie, dass ein Lüfter irgendwann
ausgefallen ist und wie das Ganze
funktionieren soll, dass der irgendwie merkt,
dass die CPU zu heiß wird.
Wie hat er gemacht?
Dann hat er den Geist aufgegeben.
...von Anfang an, klar, dass das
sehr unmöglich ist, weil hier gibt es ja
keinerlei Kommunikation mit diesem Gerät,
mit der CPU irgendwie, deswegen ist
dieses...
Bei Asus gab es damals eine Rückrufaktion von
MS-Ausbilden. Da war mein Mainboard davon betroffen.
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Lüfter bekommen von Asus dann.
Korrekt.
Athlon XP Mainboard.
Ja.
...vor 110 Grad Celsius geschützt
nach wie vor. Das ist absoluter Nonsens.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Aber
theoretisch würde
mein Lüfter ausfallen,
dann würde mich das Ding anschreien
und sagen, jo, ich hätte
ein Problem. Also, so weit, so gut.
Wie gut kühlt eigentlich so ein Jet
so ein 12.900 K?
Das scheint auch tatsächlich von
einem Flugzeug irgendwie inspiriert zu sein, weil
die haben da auch so diese
Signalleuchte eingebaut, die normalerweise
irgendwo am Flügel
des Flugzeugs ist, aber nicht
an der Turbine. Aber okay.
Also, Eitel-Temperatur passt, aber natürlich
taktet sich da die CPU auch runter und dementsprechend
passiert da sowieso
nicht viel mit Abwärme. Aber wie sieht's
mit Cinebench aus?
Direkt, direkt
Limit. Das sieht
ziemlich warm aus.
Also, wie man sehen kann, Temperaturen sind auf jeden Fall
bei den Peak-Cores direkt auf 100 Grad
Celsius. Also, wir haben hier
gerade 70 Watt, was über die CPU
abgeführt wird. Und ja, klar, dass
Cinebench ein bisschen zu viel ist, das war mir wahrscheinlich klar.
Ich hätte gedacht, Gaming geht vielleicht, aber mit
70 Watt, das wird nicht mal für
die Gaming-Last ausreichen, dass die
CPU sich nicht runter taktet.
Ein Highlight muss ich euch noch zeigen, und zwar
passiert das... Ich bin wirklich zufrieden
mit meiner Wasserkühlung,
muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Das ist jetzt ja schon, naja, dreiviertel Jahr
oder so, den neuen Rechner. Erster mit
Wasserkühlung, das Ding, das Ding tut er einfach.
Bin da echt, bin da echt
happy mit.
Wenn wir das System wieder herunterfahren...
Oh!
Okay.
Also, scheint mir so, dass der Lüfter eben
dann früh aussetzt, und dann denkt sich dieses Teil
so, oh... Das hört sich an, wie dass da gleich
was platzt. Lüfter ist schon wieder tot,
ich muss wieder rumschreien. Also,
stellt euch mal vor, jedes Mal, wenn ihr euren PC...
Das kommt übrigens auch beim Anmachen. Jedes Mal,
wenn ihr euren PC an- oder ausmacht,
schreit dieses Ding hier rum. Also,
nee. Passend zu
diesem komischen Teil hier, habe ich noch mal was
ausgegraben. Das ist von Evercool.
Evercool kennt man, die haben so ein paar obskure
Kühllösungen. Und hier haben wir
von 65 Extended Cooling System.
Das ist dieses kleine Teil
hier. Und das soll dafür sorgen,
dass der Lüfter noch 5
Minuten nachläuft, nachdem das
System ausgeschalten wurde. Denn wenn man hier
mal... Jetzt erstmal schön in Reihe
stecken alles und gucken.
Ah, nice Tastatur, die kommt mir bekannt vor.
Schaut, dann... Ne, ist ne Corsa-Tastatur.
Kommt mir nicht bekannt vor.
Ich kauf mir keine Corsa-Tastaturen
mehr. Ich hab mir der letzten
so schlechte Erfahrung gemacht.
GT-365. Also der...
Das ist wirklich... Also
physisch... Ich hab mir eine K95
Premium RGB Platinium
frag mich nicht gekauft.
Da war ich so unglücklich mit.
Ihr macht den PC aus und dann sagt der mir,
nach irgendwie einer Minute
soll der PC noch mal wärmer werden. Also die
rote Kurve zeigt mir, dass der PC
warm wird.
Eine Minute, nachdem man den ausgemacht hat.
Also...
Nee. Einfach nur nee.
Und auf der Rückseite ist das auch noch mal
detailliert erklärt, wie das funktioniert.
Ich hab mich auch gefragt, wie zur Hölle funktioniert denn
das? Ist da irgendwie ein Akku drin
oder sowas? Aber, das wird dann klar,
wenn man sich den Text hier unten durchliest. Denn da
steht, dass dieses Ding an 5V
angeschlossen ist. Und das ist wahrscheinlich 5V
Standby-Power. Das... Ah, ja gut.
Das kann dann auch nachlaufen. Okay, das ergibt
tatsächlich irgendwo Sinn. Kennt ihr ja, wenn euer
System an ist. Also... Also wirklich
brauchen tut man's nicht, weil
sobald es aus ist, dann produziert's ja
auch keine neue Hitze mehr und über das Passiv-Ding
wird genug abgeleitet.
Das Einzige, wo ich das kenne, dass manchmal
der Lüfter noch ein bisschen nachläuft, ist das Netzteil.
Bei manchen Netzteilen.
Ihr habt den Netzteilstecker,
also hier die 24 Pin angeschlossen und
das Netzteil ist einfach nur an, das System nicht.
Dann habt ihr Standby-Power. Also dass irgendwelche LEDs
leuchten und dieses Ding greift
vom Prinzip her auf die gleiche
Stromquelle zurück. Also auf 5V
Standby-Power. Und
hier unten haben wir das noch mal stehen. Ja?
Da sagt dann, dass
im Gegensatz zu normalen
Kühlern, führt es eben
dazu, dass nach dem Abschalten
die CPU-Temperatur dann weiter
sinkt. Was natürlich klar ist,
also wenn ihr normalerweise euer
System ausmacht und ihr habt hier so einen Kühler drauf,
dann ist der ja warm und läuft
erstmal nicht weiter. Was ja
auch vollkommen egal ist, weil die CPU
ist ja eh aus. Genau! Aber die CPU,
nachdem es aus ist, wird
auf jeden Fall nicht mehr warm werden.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall absolut unmöglich.
Dementsprechend ist hier auch dieser Adapter
dabei, damit wir 5V Standby überhaupt
haben. Wow, das sieht abenteuerlich aus, das Ding.
Ein ATX-Zwischenstecker.
Das sieht ja abenteuerlich aus,
das Teil. Das würde ja sehr, sehr schön aussehen.
Und dann haben wir hier unser kleines Auto.
Finde ich auf jeden Fall auch lustig.
Dass die das einfach an ein Autodesign angelehnt haben.
Warum auch immer. Und da haben wir jetzt
einen Lüfteranschluss. Der ist wahrscheinlich dafür da,
dass wenn man eben nicht 5V Standby
benutzt, sondern im Normalbetrieb.
Das sieht wirklich bescheuert aus.
...dass das dann durchgeschleust wird
zum Lüfter. Und wenn es ausgeht,
dann irgendwie 5V Standby. Ich schließe
das mal an. Dann bauen wir dieses Ding jetzt mal
final ein.
Da sahen ja F-Zero-Autos
auf dem Super Nintendo dreidimensionaler aus,
als der Aufschmuck da oben.
...dass es am 24-Pin-Stecker dran ist.
Hab auch schon den Lüfter angeschlossen.
Und das packen wir jetzt einfach mal
an den CPU-Fan
vom Mainboard.
Dann müsste das gleich funktionieren.
Dass wir das anschließen können.
Dass wir das starten können.
Bin ich sehr gespannt, was da
passiert. Also passiert
erstmal gar nichts.
Außer ich hab's falsch rum
gemacht hier.
Das wär natürlich äußerst doof.
Gleich MonkaSmoke.
Ah, die LED leuchtet grün.
Das war wohl äußerst doof.
Dann...
Lüfter läuft. Schön.
Immerhin ist es davor geschützt,
falsch angeschlossen zu werden, ohne dass es gleich
anfängt zu rauchen.
Okay.
So weit, so gut. Das hat funktioniert.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wenn wir das System
wieder ausmachen,
was dann passiert.
Außer dass es wahrscheinlich gleich das
Computer umschreien wird.
Der Lüfter läuft.
Er wird jetzt wahrscheinlich 2-3 Minuten laufen.
Aber eigentlich ist es komplett unsinnig.
Das scheint so weit
zu funktionieren.
Jetzt ist auch die LED wieder rot.
Also müsste jetzt über 5 Volt Standby
laufen, weil ich hatte erst so ein bisschen Bedenken,
weil nicht jeder Lüfter läuft mit 5 Volt.
Also gerade anlaufen ist
manchmal schwierig. Wenn ein Lüfter läuft,
mit 5 Volt weiter zu betreiben,
kann aber funktionieren, wie wir hier sehen.
Also hält,
was es verspricht, so wie es aussieht.
Ob das Ganze sinnvoll ist oder nicht,
sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum.
Weil deinem PC ist es ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal,
ob es da drin noch warm ist,
wenn man den ausmacht.
Weil theoretisch also eine CPU
im ausgeschalteten Zustand,
die kann ich auch auf 200 Grad Celsius erhöhen,
wenn ich da irgendwas rumlöten möchte oder sowas.
Und das hält die problemlos aus.
Dementsprechend sehe ich jetzt nicht, warum man sowas verwenden sollte.
Aber es hätte zumindest mal, wie gesprochen,
funktioniert.
Trotzdem sind das aus meiner Sicht
Gadgets, Tools,
die sich aus gutem Grund auch nicht durchgesetzt haben.
Also von hier der guten
SystoTech
Marke, beziehungsweise das war ja
P-Logic.
Plus noch der Fanatec
Headshot Pro Controller.
Oder wie hieß das Ding?
Doch, Fanatec
Headshot Controller.
Hat man nie wieder was gehört.
Evercool, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Die haben damals zumindest mal richtig
viel gemacht.
Also Tools,
die kein Mensch braucht, die trotzdem lustig werden.
Ich bedanke mich fürs Zuschauen,
mal zurück bis dahin.
Christian, danke für den Sub.
Ich meine den hier.
Wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will,
braucht eine Top-Ausstattung.
Und da ist der
Fanatec Headshot Controller genau das Richtige.
Das Set besteht aus einer
Ultra-
Ich muss ja mal kurz lachen, wenn ich das Ding sehe.
Das sieht so billig aus.
So schrottig, man.
Präzisen Gamer-Maus und einem
High-Speed-Pad. Zusammen ein unschlagbares Team.
Das sieht so
kacke aus.
Super ergonomisch und lässt sich an jede Handform anpassen.
Das sorgt auch in langen
Gamer-Sessions für ermüdungsfreies
Spielen. Sechs Maus-Buttons und
ein Fünf-Wege-Steuerrad sorgen dafür,
dass Sie Ihre Spielfigur auch
in heißen Gefechten im Griff haben.
Die Plasma-Gleit-Maus-Füße sorgen
zusammen mit dem High-Speed-Pad für
maximale Haft- und Gleitreibung,
für schnelles, präzises Zielen im Spiel.
Das leichte Kabel
kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert nicht
in die Quere. Dafür sorgt die
clevere Kabelführung.
Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben,
Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz
machen das Spiel noch rasanter.
RGB, bevor es RGB hieß.
Wir Gamers sind begeistert
von den Programmiermöglichkeiten für
Maus und Tastatur, selbst
während des Spiels. Auch
die Maus-Maus-Füße lassen sich problemlos einsetzen.
Damit sind Sie bei Flugsimulationen,
Rennspielen und anderen Games der King.
Der Fanatec Headshot-Controller
ist das ultimative
Set für Gamer.
Und wetten, dass er auch als Geschenk
gut ankommt? Probieren Sie es aus.
Ja, natürlich,
das ist alt. Guck mal, die Produktion war doch sogar
noch in 4-zu-3-Format.
Warum ich das auswendig kenne?
Naja, weil ich schon ein paar Mal geguckt habe.
Ich
wollte auch nur diesen einen Satz.
Der Fanatec Headshot-Controller.
Gibt
schon tolle Sachen.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Moment, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Kecke.
iPhone 15, ich konnte es aus-
Oh nee, kein iPhone.
Jetzt.
Was haben wir denn? Der Absturz von Diablo 4.
Diablo 4 soll jährliche
Add-Ons. Videos von Maurice
sind immer nice.
Und mich interessiert tatsächlich, was bei Diablo 4
abgeht, weil ich habe von Diablo 4
seit Season 1 eigentlich
kurz den Aufschrei
des Negativen gehört.
Und
danach nichts mehr.
Und ich habe das mal letztens verfolgt
auf Twitch.
Ich glaube, der ist noch bei der Gamestar, macht aber hauptsächlich
sein eigenes Ding.
Und es hat halt
Warum sieht denn das eigentlich so dumm aus,
die Übersicht hier?
Man hat halt kaum noch
Views. Guck mal hier, Browse.
What the fuck?
Twitch, Alter.
Oh Mann.
Boomer.
Genau
danach habe ich jetzt gesucht.
Also, mal gucken,
wo Diablo 4 hier steht.
Moment, Moment,
wait a minute. Diablo 3
hat mehr als Diablo 4?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Hä?
Wo ist denn Diablo 4?
Wait a minute, ist das einfach nur massive
recommended for you? Nein, nein, nein.
High to low.
Aber da war es doch eben.
Hä? Da ist es.
Okay, 4K,
das ist halt wirklich nicht viel.
Factorio ist ein mega nice
Game. Factorio
hat wohl eine recht
beliebte Speedrun Szene.
Zwar nicht riesengroß, so wie Mario 64,
aber es gibt wohl recht
viele, die da aktiv sind.
Steam Charts.
Moment, ist Diablo 4 auf Steam?
Ist das nicht so ein Blizzard?
Stimmt, das ist glaube ich auf Steam, oder?
Ist das?
Nee, nee, ist nicht auf Steam.
Ja, das ist schon die
Space Erweiterung gesehen. Nein.
Ich hätte aber echt mal wieder richtig Bock
auf ein paar Runden Factorio.
Okay, Maurice, dann erzähl uns mal,
was abgeht mit
Diablo 4.
...bekommen, haben die Entwickler verraten.
Und die braucht es auch, denn mit der
ersten Season scheint das Spiel
ziemlich übel
abgestürzt zu sein.
So kam mir das auch vor.
Blizzard, anders als zum Beispiel Steam,
keine offiziellen Spielerzahlen
rausgibt und wir es deswegen nicht an einer
ganz klaren Metrik festmachen können.
Aber alles, was
so drumherum passiert,
deutet doch sehr stark darauf hin,
dass das Spiel ein Problem hat.
In der Community stieß die erste Season
auf. Ich hab's mir nie gekauft, als riesen
Diablo-Fan, aber nach Diablo 3
irgendwie und Blizzard die letzten
Jahre über, ich hatte kein Vertrauen
mehr, was erstmal so
ausser wie, als hab ich mich getäuscht,
weil Diablo 4
richtig gut ankam, so für 3-4
Wochen, aber im Nachhinein hatte ich doch recht.
Sehr viel negatives
Feedback und auf Twitch ist das Spiel
von durchschnittlich
220.000
Zuschauern im Release-Monat
auf
2400 im September
abgestürzt. Das sind
99%
Reduktion.
Was wahrscheinlich auch daran liegt, dass damals
erst mal ein Gold und richtig viele große Streamer
gespielt haben und heute halt nicht mehr.
Aber gut, wenn ich
diesen gut verwende, würde ich es wahrscheinlich spielen.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Spielt ihr noch
Diablo 4? Chat, repräsentative
Chat-Umfrage.
Also ich nicht.
Nein.
In meinem Fall, wie gesagt,
ich hab's weggelegt und die meisten
Leute, die ich kenne, ebenfalls.
Ich find das auch erst mal
jetzt keine Katastrophe.
Ich hab's viel gespielt zum Release.
Ich hatte viel Spaß damit.
Ich mein, wenn man sich überlegt, ich hab Diablo 2
damals bestimmt
2 oder 3 Jahre gespielt.
Immer wieder.
Aber gut, es war halt online
Battle.net only und ich hab halt hauptsächlich getradet.
Aber natürlich auch
gespielt.
Es gab wenig Games, wo ich
so viele Stunden reingesteckt hab, als in Diablo 2.
Ehe, dass man nicht so ein Spiel die ganze
Zeit durchspielt. Hab ich mehr Zeit
für Baldur's Gate? Ist doch auch gar nicht
so verkehrt. Was ich übrigens auch
grade streame. Twitch.tv, Maurice Weber.
Ganz toller Kanal.
Alle reinschauen. Aber das kann
halt nicht sein, was
Blizzard gewollt hat.
Also nicht, dass ihr meinen Kanal nicht schaut, sondern
Allein schon aus diesem... Also ich kann euch auch
sagen, warum es definitiv nicht das ist, was
Blizzard sich vorgestellt hat.
Letztendlich ist es ein Vollpreis-Produkt
mit irgendeinem komischen
Season Pass und Gedöns wieder
und kaufbaren Cosmetics.
Und das funktioniert
nicht, wenn der Kram nicht
gespielt wird.
Wie lange hast du PoE gespielt?
Boah, bestimmt
nicht so lang wie Diablo 2
insgesamt von den Stunden her,
aber auch schon viel.
Ich weiß es nicht, wie viel, aber
paar hundert Stunden sicherlich.
Aber nach ein paar hundert
Stunden blickt mir ein PoE ja erstmal durch,
was man da eigentlich macht.
Denn das Ding sollte ja ein Service
Game werden und soll es immer
noch sein. Ein langfristig
gespieltes Spiel, zu dem Leute immer wieder
zurückkehren und hoffentlich
dann auch gut Geld im Shop lassen.
Das scheint jetzt aktuell...
Das funktioniert halt nicht, wenn keiner spielt.
Wie sich Blizzard das
vorgestellt hat. Blizzard veröffentlicht bestimmt
auch keine Spielerzahlen, oder? Die haben ja mit
WoW auch aufgehört, Spielerzahlen zu veröffentlichen
als es so langsam, aber
sicher ein bisschen bergrunter ging.
Es macht sich natürlich auch immer gut. Ja, man kann
immer super, super veröffentlichen,
so nach dem Motto, neuer Rekord gebrochen,
wieder Rekord gebrochen, höchster Spielerstand
ever. Aber sobald es da ein bisschen
runter geht, macht sich das halt nicht mehr so gut.
Viele Leute vermelden,
mit der ersten Season ist
die Luft ziemlich schnell raus.
Diablo 4
is currently losing the battle for my
attention to a 10 year old game.
And for once I can say that
it's not even RuneScape I'm talking about.
RuneScape!
Das ist das genaue
Gegenteil von allem, was wir
erwartet hatten, denn ich hatte
immer den Eindruck, dass sich alle
einig sind, Spieler und Blizzard,
dass die Seasons von Diablo
3 nicht ganz genug waren
und dass wir ja alle gesehen hatten,
schaut mal, Path of Exile
macht das viel besser. Das bietet
viel mehr... Aber
Shining Gear Games kriegt auch
richtig viel...
Shitstorm kann man nicht sagen,
ist es ja nicht, aber auch viel
Gegenwind in den letzten paar Jahren.
Also
gerade was die... viel Hate ab, ja.
Also man muss ja auch sagen, gerade was die
Performance angeht und
wie oft PoE crasht,
es crasht nicht komplett, es lockt dich halt aus,
ist schon ein bisschen
grenzwertig.
Pro Season.
Und das ist die Messlatte, was
Diablo 4 auch pro Season bieten
sollte. Ich hatte ehrlich gesagt
damit gerechnet, dass Season
1 ein richtig krasser Paukenschlag
wird, der zeigt, guckt mal,
BÄM! So sehen
bei Diablo 4 die Seasons aus.
Und was mit Season 1 passiert ist,
sofern ich das als Außenstehender mitbekommen
habe, ist, man hat das Gameplay verlangsamt
und alle Skills genervt.
Wie gesagt, ich spiele nicht, keine Ahnung.
Aber das war das, was ich so,
was so der
Tenor war, so durch die Bank weg.
Das Path of Exile.
Ja, war
vielleicht naiv,
aber ich dachte auch irgendwie, das
wäre der Deal. Diablo 3
kam mit seinen
eher mäßigen, also es gab ja auch
tolle Seasons, witzigerweise jetzt gerade die letzten,
da haben sie nochmal richtig angezogen,
aber es kam mit seinen Seasons ja auch gerade deswegen
durch, weil es nicht so krass
kommentarisiert war, beziehungsweise
dann ja irgendwann gar nicht mehr. Und man
auch irgendwie eingesehen hat. Ich muss sagen,
was ich an Diablo 3, was mir persönlich,
warum ich es auch nie groß gespielt habe,
die sind ja am Anfang,
hatten sie das ja, sagen wir mal,
relativ klassisch mit Traits
und Problem war damals halt das
Auktionshaus, was halt voll für'n Arsch war.
Und danach
haben sie Diablo 3 umgebaut zu
komplett self-found.
Für mich, also was für mich
diesen Reiz an Diablo 2 ausgemacht hat,
ist, dass das Spiel nicht,
das Spiel war nicht so schwer,
dementsprechend konntest du halt auch
sehr viele verschiedene Sachen
spielen. Du konntest
Dual-Wield-Wurfsperr-Barb spielen
und sowas. War eigentlich komplett für'n Arsch, aber ging
trotzdem gut mit den passenden Items und
dem passenden Build.
Und dementsprechend
konntest du, hast du viel Variationen gehabt
in Diablo 2. Wenn du natürlich wirklich
die absoluten so Min-Max
Builds spielen wolltest in Diablo 2,
dann gab's da jetzt auch nicht so viel.
Aber es war cool und
du konntest relativ viel spielen.
Und für mich war halt der
Battle.net Trading-Faktor
extrem
motivierend für mich in Diablo 2.
Trading-Channel,
kaufen, Zeug verkaufen,
wissen, was gerade angesagt ist.
Leider hat's mir das dann ein bisschen den Spaß
versaut in Diablo 2,
dass es diese riesen Dupe-Wellen gab.
Diablo 2 war ja eines der ersten richtig
so, nennen wir es mal, massively
Online-Games, was sicherlich
auch mit den Grundstein gelegt hat
für später World of Warcraft.
Von den Erfahrungen, die man dort gewonnen hat
und sowas, garantiert.
Und dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Ja, hatte ich keinen Bock mehr drauf. So und
dieser Faktor hat mir halt komplett gefehlt in Diablo 3.
Nachdem es komplett nur noch
self-found war.
Ja, das ist halt dann natürlich nicht mehr
in Diablo 3 auch vom Gameplay nicht so gut gefallen.
Wie bei Path of Exile, wo es
mit jeder Season
neue Pakete zu kaufen gibt.
Path of Exile ist eines der
ganz wenigen Free-to-Play-Spiele,
wo ich viele, viele
hunderte Stunden drinne hab
und
gleichermaßen sogar
Geld für ausgegeben hab.
Und nicht nur, sagen wir mal,
die sinnvollen Sachen, ja, zum Beispiel
die, ähm
für die Kiste, die
Tabs für
Essenzen
oder für
generell Kisten, Kistentabs für Items
und sowas. Das ist ja bei Path of
Exile zwar optional,
ist aber schon sinnvoll, wenn man das hat.
Ich hab mir sogar Hideout-Skins
und so gekauft in PoE.
Einfach, weil
es geht und ich mir gedacht hab, ey, du hast jetzt so
viel Zeit da reingesteckt, schade
doch nicht, kauf halt mal. Also
das ist das einzige Modell, was bei mir
bisher dazu geführt hat,
dass ich Geld ausgegeben habe.
Die meistens
optional sind, klar, abgesehen jetzt von
Stash-Tabs, die bei Path of Exile
echt nur so semi-optional sind.
Die sind offiziell optional, aber wenn man das
ein bisschen mehr grindet,
braucht man die. Aber bei Diablo 4 hat man sich gedacht, okay,
Battle Pass, überteuerter Shop,
alles nicht. Ich mein, niemand muss in PoE, die beim
leveln, wenn er einfach mal reingucken will,
die Kampagne durchspielen und ein bisschen
brauch keine Stash-Tabs, aber selbst da ist schon
sinnvoll. Brauchst du nicht wirklich, also kannst rein,
wirklich rein, Free-to-Play spielen. Sobald
du dann aber ein bisschen Endgame-Farm willst und so was,
ein paar Tabs sind schon
sinnig, aber die Tabs sind auch nicht so teuer.
Und bis dahin hat man ja da schon
40,
50 Stunden vielleicht
reingesteckt und
dann kann man das, denke ich, durchaus
machen und man kommt da ganz gut hin.
Also ich finde das auch eine faire
Sache bei Path of Exile. Also ich finde das
eines der besten Games in diesem
Genre und eines der besten Monetarisierungsmodelle.
Ja, Spudi,
man sieht's genauso.
Nicht so geil,
der Deal ist dann aber doch hoffentlich auch,
dass dafür auch mehr saisonaler Content
kommt. Und es gab mehr als
in Diablo 3, ja,
aber längst nicht so interessante
Mechaniken, wie Path of Exile sie bringt
und längst nicht so interessante Mechaniken,
wie wir uns alle erhofft hatten.
Path of Exile interessante Mechaniken
und Path of Exile ist mittlerweile
so extrem vollgestopft
mit Mechanics.
Du musst erst mal 300 Stunden gespielt haben,
dass du überhaupt durchblickst, was da passiert.
Du hast ja allein schon
Endgame. Der Kompass
ist, nee, nee,
wie hieß das, Map? Nee, hieß das nicht Kompass?
Wie hieß
diese Weltkartenübersicht
mit den Maps drinnen?
Ich glaub's hieß einfach nur Map.
Atlas, nicht Kompass, Atlas!
Atlas, genau, Atlas,
das mein ich.
Und die ganzen
Endgame Mechanics, weil die haben ja
aus ihren alten Ligen
oftmals die Sachen drinnen gelassen.
Also du hast dann zum Beispiel
irgendwelche Abyss-Dinger,
du hast dann
das Syndicate-Zeug
und den Garten
und
diese Organe, die du da
irgendwie deinen eigenen Boss kreieren kannst.
Path of Exile ist so
vollgestopft mit 100.000
Mini-Mechanics,
eigentlich blickst du, du kannst,
also die erste Season, die du spielst, die kannst du
nicht durchblicken. Du musst eigentlich 2, 3 Seasons
spielen, dass du überhaupt halbwegs den Plan hast,
was da überhaupt abgeht.
Ja, POE ist
Null-Einsteiger-freundlich. Wobei man das
gar nicht so sagen kann. POE kannst
du zumindest mal Kampagne von Anfang an
kannst du auch als Einsteiger
durchspielen, einfach ein bisschen Action-RPG-Cryen
gut ist, aber richtig, richtig
gut optimierte Builds und
Skills und alles,
da ist POE, ich will auch
gar nicht behaupten, dass ich da wirklich
alles durchgestiegen bin,
ist schon echt super
kompliziert.
Und ein Punkt, wo
ich tatsächlich sagen muss,
was an POE echt
Kacke ist, das ist die Kampagne.
Die Story
und die Kampagne ist so
dumm.
Du merkst richtig,
dass die Kampagne immer weitergesponnen
wurde, ohne
dass man sich Gedanken dazu drüber gemacht
hat, wie es weitergehen soll.
Also
die Kampagne geht,
die Kampagne in
POE geht schon klar,
aber die Story von POE,
die ist so unglaublich
dumm
und
unstimmig und dämlich.
Also die Story ist wirklich hängen geblieben.
Also ich glaube, niemand spielt POE
wirklich für die Story.
Die Story ist einfach so
ein wilder, unzusammenhängender
Bullshit, wie ich
das sonst in wenigen
Games gesehen habe, die so eine lange Kampagne
eigentlich haben. Also die Story ist
wirklich richtig dämlich.
Stattdessen
fällt das Spiel weiterhin so
Punkt wann zwischen Level 70 und
80 einfach eine Klippe runter.
Das war ja schon
ein Kritikpunkt zum Release.
Ab da hast du das Gefühl, mein Charakter verändert
sich jetzt kaum noch. Klar, ich
erhöhe weiter Stats durch Paragon-Punkte,
aber ich finde wenig
Spannendes. Mein Gameplay ändert
sich nicht mehr viel. Ich mache immer das
Gleiche. Nicht so Magic, nein.
Ich hab früher Yu-Gi-Oh! gespielt.
Wurzel des Problems
ist möglicherweise schlechte Planung.
Schon vor Release gab es unschöne
Berichte, dass die Entwickler massiv
Überstunden machen mussten,
um überhaupt das Grundspiel
rechtzeitig zum
anvisierten Release-Termin
fertig zu kriegen.
Also, mal wieder
typisch Gaming-Industrie.
Und möglicherweise war das Endgame
dann eben das, was als Letztes
zu Ende ging.
Also, ich glaube,
die Entwickler mussten sich
das Ende des Endgames
dann eben das, was als Letztes
feingeschliffen und finalisiert werden sollte
und zweckst Termineinhaltung
hinten runter fiel.
Season 2 verspricht
daran zumindest ein wenig zu schrauben.
Da soll es Endbosse geben,
neue Endgame-Bosse,
mit denen wir dann auch gezielt
bestimmte Items, bestimmte Uniques
sogar erfarmen könnten.
Das gibt einerseits mehr zu tun,
andererseits auch mehr
das Gefühl, er kann zielgerichtet
auf etwas hinstreben.
Das zeigt schon, dass Blizzard
das Problem ein wenig versteht
und Dinge umsetzt.
Das ist ja bei Blizzard auch schon mal etwas, ja?
Zu ändern. Wie gut diese
Sachen werden...
Ich mein, habt ihr denn keine Smartphones?
Man sieht, Blizzard versteht nicht immer,
was das Problem ist.
In Season 1 war die Mechanik leider auch
dann letztlich nicht so spannend,
wie erhofft, obwohl sie coole Ansätze hatte.
Aber das geht schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Das Problem, das Diablo 4
aber im Tieferen hat,
ist, dass Season-Änderungen, glaube ich,
nicht reichen werden, um
zu beheben, dass sich über
lange Sicht jetzt doch
herausgestellt hat, dass das Spiel
an den grundlegenden Sachen
krank, die wir in einem Action-Rollenspiel
machen, dass die langfristig
ziemlich nervig werden. Nämlich
looten und Dungeons rennen.
Fangen wir mit dem Loot an.
Ich kann es bei solchen Games auch immer
zweigeteilt sehen.
Also bei solchen langfristigen
Games. Es kann durchaus
sein, dass dieses Game übelst Spaß
macht, die Kampagne zu spielen und man richtig
Bock hat, die ersten 30-40 Stunden
zu grinden, aber man halt
keine
400 Stunden darin grinden will.
Das weiß man aber zu dem Review-Zeitpunkt
noch nicht. Du kannst ja auch von niemandem, der ein
Review macht, erwarten, dass er erstmal 400 Stunden
spielt, bis er das...
Zu dem Zeitpunkt weiß ja keiner,
wie sich das in Zukunft entwickelt.
Und der hat das
Problem, dass das Spiel
dich so zuballert,
mit konfusen, absurden,
überladenen Effekten,
dass es irgendwann mehr Arbeit
als Freude ist.
Und was ich auch gelesen
habe, ist, was die Leute richtig abfuckt,
dass du wohl Edelsteine im Inventar,
also Gems im Inventar hast
und die irgendwie genauso viel Platz brauchen
wie ein Item. Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe,
Hä? Warum?
Ich meine, in Diablo 2
war das doch ganz sinnvoll gelöst.
Diablo 2 hat einen Gem,
hat halt
einen Slot gebraucht,
einen Schädel oder so, hat halt einen Slot gebraucht.
Einen Charm hat eins bis drei
gebraucht und Waffen und Rüstung haben
je nach Größe gebraucht. Man hätte ja
sagen können, okay, alle Waffen brauchen gleich viel,
alle Rüstung brauchen... Okay, das hätte ich... Aber
warum braucht so ein Edelstein
so viel wie eine fette Rüstung? Das ergibt für mich
überhaupt keinen Sinn.
...in deinem Inventar durchzuwühlen, ob da
was Interessantes dabei ist.
Hehe.
That is one big pile of shit.
Da könnten Sachen wie Lootfilter helfen,
aber selbst wenn das grundlegende Problem
nicht... Hat Diablo 4 keine Lootfilter?
Path of Exile kannst du ohne Lootfilter
gar nicht spielen.
...dass diese Affixe zum Teil einfach
kompletter Quatsch sind. Ein Beispiel,
einfach nur ein Beispiel für Affixe,
die es alle separat gibt.
Mehr Kälteschaden, mehr Schaden
für Frostzauber, mehr Schaden
gegen unterkühlte Feinde.
Mehr Schaden bei eingefrorenen Feinden
oder sowas wahrscheinlich noch.
...mehr Schaden gegen eingefrorene Feinde.
...
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass es in Diablo 4 so ist.
Also, in PoE ist das andere extrem.
Das ist, finde ich, schon fast ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Ich weiß nicht, hat jemand von euch mal PoE-High-End,
ähm, ausgerüstete Charakter gesehen?
So am Ende von einer Season oder so?
Ich mein, du siehst ja die Monster kaum noch, bevor du weiterrennst.
Du bist im Prinzip nur damit beschäftigt,
deine Skill-Rotation zu machen, deine Flask-Rotation zu machen
und deine Movement-Skill-Rotation zu machen.
Also, PoE ist quasi zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp ...
Mäpp fertig, nächste Mäpp zapp, zapp, zapp, zapp, ...
Das ist schon fast ein bisschen zu viel des Guten, ja?
... Sehen habe.
Und warum sind die Albtraummechaniken auch so oft drauf ausgelegt,
dass ich kurz innehalten muss, unterbrochen werde?
So viele Mechaniken,
wenn ich die auf einem Schlüssel seh, dann auf einem Siegel ...
Ach nee, die Donnerkuppel wieder.
Ah, nee, okay, nee, hab ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, die sollten das Spiel schwerer machen,
und die sollten es dem Spieler natürlich anspruchsvoller machen,
diese Dungeons zu laufen.
Aber auch spaßiger.
Und das schaffen die wenigsten dieser Mechaniken.
Da gibt es wirklich tiefere systemische Probleme,
als, wie gesagt, sie leicht behoben werden könnten.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Ich hätte zum Beispiel riesig Lust
auf einfach einen richtig schönen Endlossmodus.
Einen Endlossdungeon oder einen Endlossordenmodus oder beides.
Habe ich in POE nie so wirklich gemacht, aber gibt es, ja.
Wo ich wirklich ohne Unterbrechung metzeln kann.
Es hilft übrigens auch nicht, dass dann pro Season
auch nur eine Handvoll Dungeons zu Alptraum-Dungeons werden können.
Damit schöpft Diablo 4 ja nicht mal die Vielfalt aus, die es hat,
weil du diese Dungeons auch so schnell immer wieder siehst.
Nun finde ich, wie ich schon ein paar Mal gesagt habe,
nicht, dass Diablo 4 ein komplettes Schrottspiel ist oder so.
Ich hatte sehr viel Spaß damit
und ich finde, es macht viele der wichtigsten Grundlagen sehr richtig.
Das Kampfgefühl ist wuchtig und spaßig.
Die Atmosphäre ist düster und richtig gelungen.
Die Kampagne hatte viele richtig tolle Momente.
Sie hatte auch ihre Probleme.
Ich verstehe immer noch nicht,
warum man sie nicht auf Weltstufe drei weiterspielen kann.
Aber da ist viel da, das Spaß gemacht hat.
Ich hab auch nicht das Gefühl ...
Das konnten sie schon immer gut.
Dass ich irgendwie betrogen wurde und nicht genug Spaß hatte mit dem Spiel.
Ich hab Charaktere in der Preseason aufgelevelt,
ich hab Charaktere in der Season aufgelevelt.
Ich hatte mit dem Nekromanten, dem Autocastingherz,
auch noch mal einigen Spaß in der Season.
Aber es ist noch nicht da, wo es sein sollte.
Es kann auch noch nicht da sein, wo Blizzard will, dass es ist.
Weil ein Servicegame muss, wenn es funktionieren will,
und wenn es den Leuten auch das Gefühl geben will,
dass sie ihr Geld und ihre Spielzeit auch genug bekommen,
muss es mehr bieten.
Und ich glaube, bis es mit Diablo IV soweit ist,
bis es an dem Punkt ist, an dem es sein sollte,
müssen wir mindestens auf das erste Add-on warten.
Es hat das Potenzial für den Reaper-of-Souls-Moment.
Oder den Destiny-1-Moment.
Also den Moment, wo ein großes Add-on viel umkrempelt
und das Spiel endlich an den Punkt bringt,
wo es sein volles Potenzial ausschöpft.
Und es braucht eben auch ein Add-on.
Eine Season wird nicht reichen.
Season 2 bringt sicher Verbesserungen,
auch Edelstein-Inventar und so Sachen.
Ach ja! Haben sie das jetzt endlich hingekriegt?
Ist Ihnen auch aufgefallen, dass es eine blöde Idee war,
dass in Jam so viel Inventarplatz braucht?
War noch nicht genug.
Und Blizzard muss sich da anstrengen,
weil die Konkurrenz schläft ja nicht.
Ja, und vor allem, es ist enorm schwierig,
das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, es ist enorm schwierig,
Spieler, die man verloren hat, zurückzugewinnen.
Ich sag nicht, dass es nicht geht.
Ja, also, keine Ahnung, so Sachen wie Rainbow Six oder so,
die haben das auch noch mal irgendwie in die Kurve gekriegt.
Es ist schwierig.
Du hast nur einmal die Chance,
einen guten ersten Eindruck zu machen.
Er ist auf dem Weg und sieht verdammt gut aus.
PoE 2 wird auch Hardcore-kreiselgrindet,
wenn's rauskommt.
Mein Tipp ist Last Epoch.
Das ist so ein bisschen diesmal der Underdog in diesem Rennen.
Bisschen das Grim Dawn.
Gut, dass er's erwähnt!
Das hab ich seit, keine Ahnung, drei Jahren oder so
bei mir auf der Steam-Liste stehen, wollte ich mir schon lange angucken.
Grim Dawn war damals das zwischen D3 und Path of Exile 1.
Grim Dawn kriegt übrigens wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Erweiterung.
Hätt ich auch nicht gedacht.
Also, es gibt Optionen.
Last Epoch ist mein persönlicher Geheimtipp aktuell.
mit richtig coolen Ideen und Systemen,
die ein wenig in Richtung Path of Exile gehen,
aber nicht ganz so krass sind in dem, was sie von dir verlangen.
Es hat aber zum Beispiel eigene Skilltrees für jede Fähigkeit.
Also, jede einzelne Fähigkeit
kannst du mit einem eigenen Skilltree spezialisieren.
Was für eine coole Idee.
Das Spiel, wenn ihr grade müde seid, was Diablo 4 angeht,
würde ich euch empfehlen, guckt euch das mal an.
Das kriegt auch grade ein größeres Update.
Das ist ein sehr vielversprechender Konkurrent.
Der wiederum zeigt, wie gesagt, Lizard muss mehr liefern.
Ich habe den Eindruck, das wissen wir auch.
Ist das noch Early Access? Dann spiel ich's nicht.
Okay, ich spiel's nicht.
Ich kritisiere aus Liebe in diesem Fall.
Aber ich vermute eben ...
Ich spiele keine Early-Access-Games mehr.
... noch auf das erste Add-on warten.
Selbst bei Lostgate 3 hab ich mich zurückgehalten,
das Early-Access zu kaufen.
Ich kauf keine Early-Access-Games mehr.
Alles fake, Patheo Strahle ...
Nein, wer hätte denken können, dass da was fake ist?
Das wirkte doch so superauthentisch schon die ganze Zeit.
Hab ich nie gedacht, dass da was fake ist.
Warum nicht, Max?
Warum ich keine Early-Access-Spiele mehr spiel?
Weil zu viele Early-Access-Spiele nie aus dem Early-Access rauskommen.
Auf jeden Fall einschlafen.
Da lohnt es sich nicht, die Zeit reinzustecken.
Ich hab Hunger so langsam, aber sicher.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Programmierer reagiert auf 14 Minuten.
Haben wir da irgendwas Kurzes und Knackiges?
Was ist das?
Can Linux save this outlet?
Natürlich kann Linux das safen, je nachdem, was du darauf laufen lässt.
Wenn du darauf einen aktuellen Firefox laufen lässt
und willst Webanwendungen starten, dann läuft's auch beschissen.
Dann ist egal, ob Linux oder Windows.
Ein Satz mit X?
22 Minuten zu lang.
Das ist irgendeine physie Ausbildung bei Hermes.
Da wollte ich auch reingucken.
IQ von 150.
Quasi lebender Five-Hat-Beweis.
Everything in Rust rewrite.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Mein Magen knurrt schon.
Ich geh jetzt was fuddern.
Hast du eigentlich mal in die Windows-11-23-H2-Update-Preview rein?
Nö, nö, nö.
Wieso, lohnt sich das?
Ist da irgendwas dabei, was man gucken sollte?
Wir könnten das im Stream angucken,
aber nur, wenn's da irgendwas Sinnvolles ...
Sinnvolles gibt, was sich lohnt.
PC-Welt.
Na, wenn die PC-Welt das schreibt, dann kann das nur geil sein.
Zeig mal her, was gibt's denn da Neues?
Windows-AI-Copilot juckt mich null.
KE-Gestütz-Datei juckt mich null.
Na, wenn das so gut funktioniert wie die Windows-Suche,
dann gute Nacht.
Aktualisiert das Design des Datei-Explorer.
Moment, hat das jetzt eigentlich schon Tabs?
Ja.
Noch mal ein neues Design, okay.
PC-Welt, wie wär's mit einem Screenshot dazu?
Dynamische Beleuchtung.
Dynamische Beleuchtung, integrierte Tools
zur Steuerung der RGB-Beleuchtung von Geräten und Zubehör.
Okay, das find ich cool.
Ist halt nur die Frage, ob da mein Mainboardhersteller,
Grafikkartenhersteller und RAM-Hersteller mitmacht.
Aufheben der Gruppierung von Taskleistungen.
Oh! Endlich!
Endlich!
Leute, wir müssen uns das angucken.
Moment, es wird noch nicht bestätigt.
Ach so, enthalten.
7-Zip-Out-of-the-Box, auch gut.
Das ist ja mal tatsächlich ein halbwegs sinnvolles Update.
Microsoft, was ist denn da los?
Winzig-weich-Windowf.
Cringe! Dice of Cringe, Leute.
Neue AI-Funktionen im Mail.
Juckt mich nicht. Sicher wiederherstellen von Apps.
Okay, whatever.
Neue Einstellungen, Startseite, HDR, Desktop-Hintergrundbilder.
Aktualisiertes Menü für die Sauna.
Überarbeitet der Apps für Notepad und Snipping-Tool.
Copilot ist wohl die aufregendste Neuerung.
Quatsch, geht mir am Arsch vorbei.
Entkopierbare Apps ist viel wichtiger.
Ach so sieht der neue Explorer jetzt aus.
Okay, Leute, ich würd sagen,
das müssen wir uns heute Abend vielleicht mal angucken.
Windows 11 23H2 hieß das, gell?
Chet- ... Chetgis, äh ...
23H2.
Bing Daily Image of the Day, ja, das wär mal ganz cool.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab keine Hoffnung drin,
dass der Explorer das jemals gut kann.
Windows 10, wahrscheinlich Windows 11 auch noch,
hatte das Problem, dass wenn der Desktop voller Icons ist
und du das Taskmenü gestartet hast, dass es gelaggt hat.
Das ging dann, wenn du es ein paar Mal schnell auf- und zugemacht hast,
hing es einfach für vier, fünf Sekunden.
Macht es das?
Bann, ja, Bann müssen wir uns auch noch angucken.
Also, aber nicht, ob ich da Hirnkapazitäten heute für hab.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich würde nie mit meinem Arbeits-PC da reingehen.
Ich würd mir das einfach parallel in irgendeiner VM installieren.
Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit.
Aber können nicht alle.
Und wollen auch gar nicht alle.
Darf man ja auch nicht vergessen.
Ich bin happy mit meiner Kombination aus Linux für fast alles
und Windows für Gaming und Videogramm und Streaming.
Zumal ich einfach umschalten kann zwischen zwei Desktops.
Und dann hab ich Linux im Fullscreen und Windows im Fullscreen.
Easy.
Zack, Windows Fullscreen.
Linux Fullscreen.
Linux Fullscreen, Windows Fullscreen.
Eats.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen ...
Und wer hat so ein geiles Terminal,
dass er Images anzeigen kann, sogar animierte GIFs, ne?
Pogu.
Pogu-Türm.
Der Türm-Champ.
So.
Chat.
Jetzt ist es soweit.
Jetzt geh ich was essen.
Ratet mal, was es heute gibt. Ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Ihr, ihr kommt, ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Äh, what the fuck?
Ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Jawohl, es gibt Nudeln mit Lachs.
Du brauchst die Wallpaper, dann geh auf GitHub.
Wo belohnt's whitepaperhappy-desktop?
Und da findest du für jede Tageszeit einen passenden Wallpaper.
Sogar Workout-Time hier.
Und wenn du Linux verwendest,
kannst du entweder mein Script oder das Skript von Max verwenden.
Was dir automatisch alle zehn Minuten den Desktop changed.
Oder du benutzt, setzt manuell ein Bild.
Oder du nimmst das Desktop-Change-Software deines Desktops.
Das ist egal. Die Bilder sind alle hier drin.
Images.
Und falls jemand ein neues Hintergrundbild braucht,
ich hab gehört, der Rackman lässt sich da bestechen zu im Discord.
Aber immer unter der Auflage,
dass das Bild open-sourced wird in dem Reddit.
Gibt es für Windows ein Skript? Nee, bis jetzt haben wir noch keins.
Geben tut's das bestimmt.
Wahrscheinlich ist das mit PowerShell auch relativ easy machbar.
Also, wenn's dir danach ist,
lass dich aus, und dann packen wir das auch ins Repo rein.
Gibt es bestimmt.
Mich würde sogar wundern, wenn es das nicht sogar schon fertig gäbe.
So, Leute, ich hab Megahunger. Ich geh jetzt was fressen.
Bis denn, wir sehen uns. Und hören uns.
Also, wir hören uns, wir sehen uns.
Wir sehen uns. Und hören uns.
Wir hören uns, wir sehen uns eigentlich nicht.
Ist eigentlich Blödsinn. Wir hören uns nur.